[Musique]
Charles Henri galis olivier de la Marche
bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir bonne année
bonne année également nous vous recevons
pour une chaîne internet qui s'appelle
serw nous sommes en direct on va parler
ce so ir migration
immigration énergie économie est-ce que
vous voulez bien vous présenter
succintement monsieur Galois alors
succintement je suis charleshenri Galois
je suis le président du Mouvement
génération frexit et je me suis toujours
intéressé aux questions évidemment
économiques et les deux grands défis ce
que j'appelle dans mon livre du 21e
siècle que vont être selon moi énergie
et immigration et je pense qu'on aura
l'occasion de le développer
olivier de la Marche bonsoir bonsoir bah
écoutez olivier de la Marche je fais un
peu parti des meubles ici table basse
c'est ça la table
basse économiste patron d'un family
office à Genève
et récemment parti de France pour aller
m'installé en Suisse voilà bah bravo ben
oui bravo j'en ai
marre
on en rediscutera d'ailleurs pour Mar
Charles Henri pourquoi la relation de
cause effet a été traitée dans votre
bouquin énergie im migrant c'est une
relation de cause à effet ou pas alors a
priori on peut penser que ce sont deux
sujets qui sont complètement différents
même si pour moi ce sont de grandes
thématiques disons ce qui peut les
relier il y a il y a deux dimensions
selon moi il y a celle du réchauffement
climatique on sait qu'avec le
réchauffement climatique ça va amener
des déplacements de population et donc
ça va accentuer les flus migratoires qui
sont déjà problématiques pour un pour un
pays comme la France et après il y a
l'autre dimension c'est-à-dire comment
justement on pourrait fixer les
populations parce que c'est jamais de
guêé de cœur qu'on quitte son pays et on
va pas fixer les populations dans les
pays du Sud si on narrive pas à
développer ces pays et ce que j'explique
dans le livre c'est que l'énergie
finalement c'est le c'est le sang de de
l'économie l'énergie enfin l'économie
c'est comme dit souvent char le gaav
c'est que de l' l'énerg transformée et
donc si on si au niveau énergétique ces
payslà n'ont pas une énergie abondante
et bon marché il y aura jamais de
développement de ces pays-là et faut pas
croire que les populations vont rester
donc c'est le lien en fait qu'on peut
faire entre les deux même si dans mon
ouvrage il y a cette transition
finalement que j'expose mais je traite
séparément quand même des des deux
sujets des deux problématiques
Olivier
écoute alors première chose je crois
qu'il y a un autre il y a un autre pan
euh de ça c'est c'est la démographie qui
qui fait que
justement il y a cette cette immigration
qui est en plus voulu par certains
gouvernements pour compenser la baisse
de la de la
natalité des pays on a vu ça en
Allemagne on a vu ça avec Angela Merkel
qui a fait quand même venir presque 2
millions je crois de de de de
d'étrangers euh plus d'un million pour
la seule année 2015 ouis voilà et euh et
donc
euh et pourquoi bah tout simplement
parce que l'Allemagne était autour de
entre 1,50 et 1,60 euh de taux de
fécondité euh je vous rappelle que c'est
de1 le taux de de renouvellement des
générations et donc euh ils étaient très
en dessous maintenant ce qu'il faut voir
c'est que euh euh la démographie euh en
2023 a plongé mais réellement plongé
dans beaucoup de pays l'Italie est à 12
20 l'Espagne c'est pareil Portugal c'est
pareil la Grèce c'est encore plus
bas l'Allemagne reste autour de 1,50
1660 je pense qu'on finira l'année en
France plutôt entre 1660 et
170 donc loin de ce qu'on annonce encore
et de ce qu'on était encore l'année
dernière et l'année d'avant où on était
autour des 80 84 un 82 c'est un plus bas
depuis la crise de 93 donc c'est c'est
un effondrement et et donc évidemment
bah ça ça ça pose des questions euh vous
savez que le le le un pays qui vieillit
c'est un pays dans lequel vous avez une
croissance potentielle qui est très
faible euh parce que je vous rappelle
que le le PIB à à au 2 ti3 dans les pays
occidentaux est constitué de la
consommation des ménages donc évidemment
quelqu'un qui a 75 ans et bien il
consomme moins que quelqu'un qui en a 40
ou 45 tout simplement parce que ça
retraite déjà minable depuis un bon bout
de temps et que en
plus il y a des envies qui sont moindres
dans ces dans ces âgesl donc on sait que
ça va peser sur la sur la consommation
et c'est pour ça qu'Angela Merkel avait
fait venir de des des immigrés le
problème c'est que il y a tout d'un coup
un afflux d'immigrés 1 million en un an
donc c'est quand même beaucoup et que
vous ne pouvez pas intégrer un million
de personnes en un an c'est pas possible
et en plus il se trouve que bah pas de
chance c'était pas le deal de départ où
elle avait dit que plus ou moins elle
allait faire rentrer des des des
médecins et des ingénieurs
euh malheureusement c'était pas des
médecins et des ingénieurs et 5 ans plus
tard il n'avait toujours pas de boulot
et donc évidemment bah dans ces cas-là
c'est pas vos sources concernant le
l'utau d'emploi de du million là ah ben
ça ça a été ça a été donné par les
services de de de économique de de
l'Allemagne donc VO c'est des trucs qui
sont sûrs 5 ans plus tard les les la
grande majorité des des des immigrés de
C immigration récente hein je parle pas
de du reste se retrouver se retrouver
sans donc ça veut dire que dans ces
cas-là ça ne fait pas augmenter le PIB
au contraire donc voilà et
malheureusement c'est quelque c'est une
tendance qu'on retrouve dans aujourd'hui
beaucoup de pays occidentaux qui sont
confronté à une baisse de la natalité et
à une une une perte démographique parce
que en
Italie il y a des pertes de population
c'est-à-dire qu'on est arrivé non
seulement à ce que la population
vieillisse
mais même en prenant en compte
l'immigration vous avez une baisse de la
population en Italie donc
évidemment comme vous l'avez d'ailleurs
au Japon au Japon c'est la même chose
aujourd'hui ils sont 125 millions il est
prévu qu'en 2050 il soit entre 80 et 90
millions donc ils auront perdu quasiment
un tiers de leur population ce qui'est
pas rien et ce qui va avoir énormément
d'effets économi ement parlant
c'est-à-dire que on va se retrouver
avec probablement l'immobilier qui va
s'écrouler parce que ça ça veut dire
qu'il aura à un moment 20 millions de
logements vid donc c'est pas rien quand
même he
donc ça fait pas monter l'immobilier he
dans ces cas-là et donc vous avez un un
tas de conséquences et sur bah le mode
de fonctionnement du pays parce que
qu'est-ce qu'on va faire pour pour
remplacer l'énergie pour remplacer alors
ils ont trouvé ils ont pensé trouver il
y a quelques années le le le truc c'est
ils sont dit la dette va remplacer le
pétrole en fait en gros hein mais
malheureusement ça marche pas ça c'est
une boutade non c'est pas une boutade
c'est je pense que réellement il se il
comme il n'avaient plus ils arrivaient
au bout de de la la
croissance je dirais
énergétique avec une énergie pas chère
ils sont dit bon bah faut qu'on trouve
faut qu'on trouve un truc pour faire de
la croissance à partir de quelle année
ça oh ben on va dire on va dire très
nettement à partir de de de 2000 et puis
avec un gros gros coup d'accélérateur à
partir de 2008 jusqu'à 2000 vous étiez
sur des des ratios qui étaient qui
étaient autour de 50 60 % du PIB à peu
près dans les dans les grands pays vous
étiez autour de 50 60 % du PIB et puis
après 2008 qu'est-ce qu'on qu'on a fait
en fait on a on les États ont repris la
dette privée et on fait par un petit jeu
de bonne tau l'ont fait passer en dette
publique et à ce moment-là B on s'est
retrouvé avec une dette publique qui
tangentait les S et puis qui a dépasser
les 100 et maintenant il y a plus un
seul pays qui
soit qui soit en dessous de 100
l'Allemagne encore légèrement en dessous
mais c'est ouais ENF si on prend oui si
si on les prend vous travz tous les deux
dans la finance ou dans l'économie
est-ce que vous avez regardé pourquoi il
y a une baisse de la natalité en Europe
pourquoi qu quelles seraient les
raisons il y en a il y en a plusieurs
généralement c'est ce que ce que je
disais le plus bas qu'on va avoir en
France là cette année ça rejoint 1983 où
on était aussi dans une situation de
crise économique et on sait pertinemment
que de toute façon quand les ménages
n'ont pas confiance en l'avenir ça naide
pas pour pour pour vouloir faire des
enfants parce que aucun parents ou
futurs parents ne veut laisser ses
enfants dans un monde qui va se
popériser en lui disant bah mon fils ma
fille tu vas être plus pauvre que moi et
il y a aussi la problématique spécifique
européenne qui est en partie liée à à
l'immigration de de l'insécurité parce
que ce qui c'est ce qui a commencé à
toucher du doigt Olivier c'estàdire
qu'on on a fait une sorte de enin les
dirigeants européens on fait une sorte
de raisonnement Excel en se disant parce
que il y a cette baisse de la
démographie
on va remplacer par des populations
immigrées comme si les humains étaient
substituables exactement comme des
marchandises on va les remplacer ça va
ça va bien se passer je rappelle voilà
exactement je rappelle quand même que en
France l'année dernière pour ce qui est
de la seule immigration légale on a fait
venir plus de 470000 personnes 470000
personnes pour que les gens les en tête
c'est l'équivalent de la population de
la ville de Toulouse qui est la 4e ville
de France c'est qu'en 2 ans vous faites
venir l'équivalent de la ville de
Marseille qui est la deuxième ville de
France et en un peu plus de 4 ans vous
avez la population de Paris la première
ville de France comment on peut imaginer
2 secondes qu'on va la population de
Paris population de Paris la baissé on
était à 2 millions maintenant on doit
être 1 million entre 100008 et 2
millions je crois parce que Paris fait
que de perdre de la population parce que
c'est une ville qui devient in tramurose
tramurose pas avec l'agglomération là on
est on est à 10 mais mais ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que comment on peut
penser 2 secondes qu'on va
assimiler ou même ne serait-ce
qu'inttégrer autant de monde parce que
en fait c'est une question de nombre
c'est même pas qu'une question d'origine
des populations si demain vous faites
venir 4 millions de Français au Mexique
mais ça va changer fondamentalement le
Mexique parce que 4 millions de
personnes ils vont vivre à la française
ils vont vivre entre eux c'està-dire
qu'on assimile toujours des minorités
des individus on ne peut pas assimiler
des peuples et quand vous quand vous
faites venir près de 500000 personnes
par an ce n'est pas gérable les
Portugais les Italiens on les a bien
assimilé oui mais c'était c'était dans
des nombres bien plus faibles dans une
base de population qui était bien plus
homogène à la base c'est-à-dire queil y
avait pas ce stock d'immigration comme
c'est le cas à l'heure actuelle parce
que non seulement toutes les personnes
qui arrivent on dit grosso modo qu'il y
a 9 % d'étrangers en France sauf que
depuis 2007 on fait 120000
naturalisations par an donc c'est-à-dire
que le le stock et n'est pas du tout
aussi homogène qu'il l'était qu'il
l'était à l'époque et à l'époque en plus
ils allaient pas tout tous au dans les
mêmes endroits c'était quand même assez
réparti au contraire les populations
portugaise espagnoles 2e 3e génération
elles sont totalement assimilé elles
sont totalement intégrées parce que
c'est c'est avant tout en fait une
question de nombre on peut encore une
fois assimiler des des des quantités
assez faibles on peut pas assimiler
autant donc se pose la question de com
quelle quantité on peut assimiler selon
vous moi je pense que compte tenu du
stock d'immigration qu'on a déjà en
France on pourrait assimiler quelques
dizaines de milliers de personnes par an
mais pas du tout des centaines de
milliers et occurrence quasiment un demi
million comme comme on fait à l'heure
actuelle je pense que c'est complètement
irréaliste et d'ailleurs vous avez
remarqué qu'à l'époque on parlait
d'assimilation maintenant c'est
totalement abandonné on on ne prétend
même plus en fait assimiler on parle
plus ou moins d'intégration en fait
c'est à l'anglo-saxon c'est c'est le
McDonald's venez comme vous êtes en fait
c'est respecter les lois venez comme
vous êtes et peu importe donc on arrive
à une société qui est communautarisée
une société communautarisée elle est
toujours beaucoup plus violente et on le
voit dans les chiffres quand vous prenez
les chiffres de la délinquence il y a
une surreprésentation des étrangers ils
sont 8 % de la population ils sont
quasiment un/4 des des personnes qui
sont en prison c'est quoi votre source
bah vous prenez le ministère de
l'Intérieur pour les places de prison il
ils font des des STATIS il y a 19000
19000 étrangers dans les prisons en
France donc c'est à peu près c'est 23 %
on n'est pas loin du quart il représente
9 % de la population combien de de place
d'accueil de prison en France on est
censé en avoir 60000 mais comme il a la
surpopulation carcérale on est à 75000
ce qui est très intéressant parce qu' a
un gros problème de laxisme judiciaire
en France pourquoi il y a du laxisme
judiciaire il y a deux causes il y a
l'idéologie des juges qu'on peut
considérer comme laxiste on a supprimer
les les peines les peines planché mais
il y a aussi le fait que finalement
comme vous n'avez plus de place de
prison les juges disent bah on fait de
l'aménagement de peine ou on va vous
mettre du surcil plutôt que de vous
mettre du ferme parce que de toute façon
il y a plus de place de prison si vous
expulsiez les 19000 étrangers
délinquants qui sont en prison bah vous
vous auriez des places de prison donc il
y a un problème aussi de de con ution
faut pas se leurer Emmanuel Macron avait
promis d'en construire 15000 à la fin de
son premier mandat vous savez combien on
a construit à date entre 2000 et 3000 et
alors qu'il faudrait on estime les
spécialistes les crimin les
criminologues estiment qu'il faudrait à
peu près 100000 places de prison en
France et en plus de ça il y a un stock
à l'heure actuelle qui est pris par des
étrangers dlincant et le problème et ça
c'est le problème des des règles
européennes c'està-d qu'on expulse pas
ou très peu les étrangers délinquants
c'est la même chose pour les otf c'est
la même chose pour les fichers
parce que tout le droit européen fait
que en fait ça ne sert quasiment à rien
c'est-à-dire que vous êtes dans le cadre
de l'Espace Schengen donc vous pouvez
les expulser du jour au lendemain ils
peuvent revenir par l'Espagne par la
Grèce par l'Italie donc à quoi en fait
les à quoi ça sert de les expulser
quasiment rien et vous avez un autre
élément qui est hallucinant c'est la
directive retour de 2008 alors il y a
plein de choses dans cette directive
retour il y a le fait de non refoulement
vous pouvez pas refouler des clandestins
qui voudra arriver en France c'est
pourquoi c'est dans cette directive de
l'Union européenne de 2008 la directive
retour il y a le principe de non
refoulement des migrants qui arrivent
d'un autre pays de l'Union européenne
qui arrivent à vous frontière et il y a
un autre point qui est hallucinant
c'est-à-dire que dans cette directive de
2008 il est mis explicitement et c'est
pour ça que quand nous avez des
clandestins qui sont déboutés 60 % ils
restent tous sur le territoire national
parce que dans cette directive vous avez
le fait que même si vous appréhendez un
clandestin le retour doit être
volontaire c'est vous n'avez pas le
droit de le prendre de le mettre dans un
centre de rétention et de l'expulser le
retour doit être volontaire et c'est
pour ça que tous les déboutés du droit
d'asile restent en France en plus des
procédures qu' peut y avoir via la CEDH
via la cgue il y a le principe de retour
qui doit être volontaire donc dans ces
conditions-là évidemment qu'en fait on
ne fait quasiment rien et c'est là que
vous voyez le grotesque de la
communication de Gérald larmanin vous
avez peut-être suivi depuis l'affaire
des émeutes depuis l'affaire aussi de
Dominique Bernard Gérald d'armanin sur
Twitter maintenant il est tout content
chaque jour il donne une liste regardez
j'ai expulsé tant d'étrangers dangereux
et cetera alors j'ai calculé sur le
dernier trimestre de 2023 en moyenne il
expulsait 15 personnes par jourir
formidable 15 personnes par jour vous
l'annualisez ça fait 5500 personnes par
an ça veut dire que ça représente 8 %
des eqtf qui sont appliqués ça veut dire
que pour les seuls ETF prononcés en 2022
faudrait 12 ans pour tous les expulser
donc donc c'est là que vous voyez que
c'est une communication grotese mais
dans la réalité en fait on nagit
toujours pas pour protéger les Français
vous avez suivi en fait est-ce que vous
avez fait la même démarche pour les
États-Unis avec les reconductions à la
frontière les expulsions et le taux de
migrant qui passe la frontière par jour
non je l'ai pas je l'ai pas vu pour les
États-Unis parce que mon mon livre est
centré sur la problématique de la France
surner imigration qui est valable pour
vous deux en quoi olivier de la Marche
économiste non démographe non
spécialiste d' migration non spécialiste
du marché du travail non spécialiste du
de pas grand-chose sur le sujet du jour
est-il pertinent pour intervenir ça fait
beaucoup de non spécialiste là non mais
c'est valable pour vous deux donc
charleshenry répond et ensuite
Oliv donc ça veut dire que quand tu es
économiste tu ne peux que parler
d'économie or la démographie est une des
composantes de l'économie d'anticipation
évidmentanticipation donc de même que
l'énergie donc euh je suis absolument
désolé pour ton intervenant mais euh h
Raphaël Raphaël ben Raphaël votre
question est non
pertinente non c'est la même chose
c'estàd qu'on peut pas parler d'économie
si on prend pas en compte l'énergie je
parle beaucoup de d'industrie de
réindustrialisation dans mon livre faut
quand même savoir que pour certains
secteurs les secteurs les plus énergiv
au niveau industriel l'énergie c'est
parfois 60 % du coup de revient en fait
vous pouvez pas traiter de cette
question là sans traité de l'énergie
donc évidemment que toutes ces
questionsl sont liées c'est la même
chose au niveau démographique parce que
Olivier a déjà expliqué les liens qu'il
y avait au niveau évidemment de la
problématique des retraites au niveau de
la consommation au niveau du marché
immobilier et au niveau de même de
l'épargne on peut prendre toutes les
composante économique en fait ces
éléments sont fondamentaux donc de dire
qu'il y aurait pas de lien c'est cette
question ne me paraît pas très
pertinente vous êtes formé comment pour
appréhender lesmigrations vous avez été
voir qui vous avez été fou est où en
terme de données de Data vous avez été
sur le
terrain j'ai regardé énormément de de
statistiques le livre est très sourcé il
y a plus de de 150 notes de bas de page
donc tous les chiffres que j'annonce les
chiffres de du nombre d'immigrés le
chiffres de d'étrangers en prison les
chiffres des des lits tout est sourcé en
fait dedans donc en fait j'ai pris les
bases de données de la France et je me
suis aussi intéressé à d'autres pays
européens qui montrent d'ailleurs la la
problématique de migration massive qui
empêche l'assimilation il y a un cas
aussi qui est très symbolique Olivier
parlait de de l'Allemagne c'est le cas
de la Suède la Suède on parle d'un pays
de à la base 8 millions d'habitants ils
ont fait venir 2 millions d'immigrés en
en quelques années il y avait pas plus
paisible et plus calme que la Suède
comme pays européen maintenant déjà été
en Suède maintenant maintenant ils ont
dû envoyer l'armée parce qu'il y a des
guerres de gang et c'est un des pays
maintenant la Suède c'est le pays qui a
le taux de viol le plus important
d'Europe alors que c'était parmi les
plus bas c'estàd que ce taux là il a
plus que doublé en en l'espace de 10 ans
donc on voit bien en fait toute la la
problématique d'assimilation en fait
l'immigration massive empêche toute
assimilation et c'est pas un service en
fait qu'on rend à la fois aux personnes
qui viennent parce qu'on peut pas
accueillir énormément de monde dans de
bonnes conditions mais aussi à tous les
immigrés de 2e 3e génération qui eux
sont intégrés eux sont assimilés eux ont
fait les efforts en fait vont souffrir
de l'image que ces gens-là vont donner
il y a beaucoup de personnes issues de
l'immigration qui comprennent que
l'immigration massive est un gros
problème et d'ailleurs quand je parlais
des faits de délinquence la plupart des
faits de délinquence se font dans ces
quartiersl les premières victimes sont
des gens eux-mêmes issu de l'immigration
qui eux jouent le jeu et eux s'intègrent
donc en fait c'est pas une une
problématique racialeutre c'est une
problématique de nombre une
problématique de de respect de de
l'étatuss comment vous avez réussi à
faire le le la corrélation entre
immigration et délinquence ça vous avez
vu ça où bah toutes les vous prenez
toutes les statistiques en fait il y a
une surreprésentation vous prenez toutes
les catégories de qui de du ministère de
l'Intérieur ministère de la Justice vous
prenez toutes les les catégories du code
pénal vous avez entre un étranger et un
français et je parle vraiment d'étranger
je parle pas mê un étranger et un
français vous avez selon les types de
délit une surreprésentation entre un
rapport entre 2 et 10 j'ai toutes les
statistiques dans le livre donc ça ça
montre bien que le le rapport est direct
en fait entre immigration et délinquant
ce qui veut pas du tout dire que tous
les immigrés sont des délinquants la
majorité des immigrés ne sont pas
délinquants mais il y a une
surreprésentation des immigrés dans la
délinquence et donc on peut évidemment
se faire ce lien il suffit de prendre
d'ailleurs les les les violences
gratuites vous prenez dans les
transports en île-de-fance c'est plus de
80 % en fait c'est des populations
étrangères donc évidemment qu'il y a un
lien en fait quiconque regarde les
chiffres en sachant que la France en
plus donne c'est peu de chiffres on a
vraiment que la distinction entre
national et étranger mais il y a
d'autres pays européens qui ont des
statistiques beaucoup plus étendu qui
vont même justement sur personnes issus
d'immigration et autres et on voit une
surreprésentation ça reste une minorité
des personnes étrangères ou issus
d'immigration mais une surreprésentation
ce qui est normal ce qui est normal
parce qu'on le voit quand vous faites
venir des personnes d'Afghanistan ou de
Syrie mais ils ont pas les les mêmes
codes culturels c'estàd que vous allez
dans ces pays-là vous volez on vous
coupe la main il y a un
déjà été en Afghanistan ou en Syrie non
mais je je je sais comment ça marche
vous avez le la loi qui marche comme ça
là-bas donc c'estàdire que ces personnes
quand elles arrivent en France elles
font la même chose vous avez le droit à
un rappel à l'ordre
elle rigolent en fait c'est que le la
justice n'est pas du tout la même dans
CP en France et d'ailleurs vous prenez
les taux de criminalité dans les pays du
Maghreb ils sont extrêmement faibles
parce que vous avez une justice qui est
très sévère ils savent très bien que
s'il y a un seul problème ça va mal se
passer mais sauf que France vous n'z pas
du tout la même réponse pénale et donc
vous avez ce laxisme judiciaire qui
entretient ce phénomène de de
délinquence avec des ce qui est normal
c'est pas un jugement de valeur mais ce
qui est normal vous avez des cultures
différentes et donc des modes de penser
et d'appréhension notamment vis-à-vis de
de la réponse judiciaire qui est
différente selon les pays donc quand
vous faites venir en masse ces
populations il faut pas croire que ça va
bien se passer
Olivier l'immigration en France rapporte
combien
l'état coûte immigrés qui travaillent en
France cooute à l'état quels sont vos
sources quels sont vos chiffres quels
sont tes chiffres quelles sont tes
sources alors moi j'ai pas j'ai pas
parce que moi moi j'ai vu des chiffres
et j'ai vu des sources comme quoi les
immigrés qui travaillaient en France il
cotisaient non le rapport des
contribuables Associés donne un coup
l'immigration de 54 milliards d'euros
par an ce qui ce qui ce qui est au fond
logique ce qui est au fond logique parce
que il y a pas que les les cotisations
vous avez de la même façon qu' a une
surreprésentation dans la délinquence
quand vous prenez le taux de chômage
chez les étrangers le taux de chômage
est bien supérieur à ce qu'il est chez
les chez les Français d'ailleurs qu'
soit issu de l'immigration ou entre
guillemets de de souche donc c'est les
statistiques très claire qui le montre
après il y a il y a d'autres
problématiques on sait que l'ame ça
coûte ça coûte aussi d'argent l'aide
médicale d'État ça coûte près d'un
milliard d'euros par an vous avez tout
un tas de dispositifs quand il y a un
clandestin carri en France il a le droit
à un hébergement d'urgence ce que n'a
pas d'ailleurs le le SDF français so dit
en passant il a le droit aussi à une
allocation donc vous avez tout un tas de
systèmes qui fait que ça va ça va coûter
de l'argent alors évidemment par
ailleurs il y a des cotisations et
autres mais ce ce rapport en
l'occurrence de des contribu associés
c'est le rapport qui est sorti en 2023
l'année dernière chiffre à 54 milliards
le coût de l'immigration par an en
France
Olivier je le laisse là-dessus sur sur
les les chiffres moi j'ai le alors je
rebondis encore sur les les remarques de
notre ami
Raphaël qui qui nous demandit les
sources et cetera moi j'ai fait une
étude sur le sur la démographie et la
dépendance en 2017 euh alors si il la
veut tu pourras lui envoyer ma lettre
euh sur la démographie et les sources
c'est très simple hein c'est c'est les
rapports des Nations Unies c'est il y a
plusieurs organismes qui font des
rapports très
détaillé en démographie et c'est là
qu'on voit que en fait il y a il y a
il y a une une impasse totale
c'est-à-dire que quand on fait ce qui ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
tous les
systèmes
sociaux notamment ont été faitquant ils
ont été faits au lendemain de la guerre
d'accord dans les années 50 60 et et à
ce moment-là tu avais une une un
environnement qui était totalement
différent il y avait pas de chômage il y
avait une natalité qui était largement
au-dessus du du du on a fait venir
énormément d'immigrés pour per au manque
de main d'œuvre tout à fait mais on
avait pas de chômage on avait une
croissance qui était très forteé
maintenant on avait une croissance qui
était autour de 6 7 % du PIB pas rien
d'accord et là et on
avait dans les années 60 on avait une
dette qui était très très
faible donc on se retrouve
avec donc des des des une construction
de des des
des mode de sécurité sociale et et
compagnie et puis maintenant on est dans
un cas où
euh on a une grande majorité de vieux et
de plus en plus où on a un chômage
endémique qui est très fort parce que il
y a que Bruno Le Maire qui pense qu'on
est en plein emploi on n est pas et on
des trones glorieus voilà la veille des
30ente glorieuses et et en plein emploi
c'est du foutage de gueule complet
donc on est loin de ces de ces chiffres
là on a une croissance qui est
anémique la la Banque de France a
réévalué ses prévisions elle a doublé
ses prévisions oui de 01 à 02 pour le 4e
trimestre alors c'est formidable mais
peut-être qu's vont le réviser dans 3
mois ils vont nous dire que finalement
c'était peut-être 01 ou Z0 et donc c'est
toujours pareil en fait quand vous
regardez quand vous regardez les
chiffres de de PMI l'étude de PMI en
fait pour ceux qui ne savent pas la
production l'indice composite de de PMI
qui est l'indice de standard pours qui
est finalement une enquête statistique
dans tous les secteurs des directeurs
d'achat et ça permet de voir un petit
peu où on en est au niveau conjoncture
on estime que quand on est sous les 50
on est en récession la France est à 44
c'est parmi les pays les plus bas
d'Europe en fait et donc c'est vra qu'il
y a une sorte de décorrélation entre le
chiffre du PIB qui annoncé alors même
s'il y avait le PIB était - 01 au 3è
trimestre là onù nous annonce qu'il sera
à 0,2 j'attends de voir le chiffre
corrigé à la fin oui oui enfin on est en
récession mais le le problème est même
pas là parce que là on va dire c'est
conjoncturel c'est cette année ça sera
pas l'année prochaine ok mais le le seul
fait de de tout l'environnement actuel
est que ton potentiel de croissance il
est entre 0 et 1 bon donc entre 0 et 1
avec des vieux avec beaucoup de
chômage avec euh euh un endettement qui
est plétorique et qui pèse sur la
croissance le taux de chômage actuel il
est combien
je pense que le réel le le réel taux de
chômage est au-dessus de 20 et le le tau
c'est-à-dire le taux quand je te dis
chômage c'est pas chômage au sens strict
c'est-à-dire le type qui va recevoir des
allocations chômage c'est pas ça c'est
que tu as tout le le allo du chômage
c'est-à-dire en fait il faut savoir que
le gars qui touche le RSA qui est
complètement sorti de de en fait des
statistiques du chômage le type qui
touche le RSA il travaille pas on est
bien d'accord il est au chômage travaux
il fait des travaux de combien d'heures
là enfin il fait oui c'est ce qu' nous
mettre en place puis il y a deux
problèmes il y a le
le sont pas sont ne
sont tout ce qui est hors catégoria a
n'est pas comptabilisé dans le chômage
or ces gens-là de fait ils sont quand
même
chômeur tu as en plus de ça tout ce qui
est euh euh contrat à durée déterminé et
à temps partiel mais pas voulu à temps
partiel imposé subi tous ces gens-là si
tu les si tu
les prends et que tu fais ton calcul de
réellement de gens qui sont en
sous-emploi on va dire et bien à ce
moment-là je pense que tu es entre 20 et
24 de toute façon si on prend toutes les
catégories de la Darès on est à plus de
on est à plus de 6 millions de personnes
et en fait c'est tout le problème où il
y a l'INC qui est le chiffre du chômage
qui annoncit tout le temps qu' en fait
c'est une enquête statistique
qu statistique comme il disit churchield
je crois toutes les statistiques parce
que c'est moi qui les ai c'est moi qui
les ai
tordu là le Pôle emploi pour le coup
enfin ex Pôle Emploi donc maintenant
DARES c'est vraiment les gens qui sont
inscrits en sachant que par ailleurs il
y a des radiations et autres ben si on
prend ces gens-là même hors radiation
aut il y a 6 millions de personnes qui
sont inscrites à à laades donc ça fait
bien plus de chômage que les 7 % qui
sont annoncés donc effectivement il y a
il y a toujours un jeu sur le le le taux
de chômage mais quand on comprend la
réalité alors ça a baissé on était un
peu plus de de 6 millions ça a un petit
peu baissé comme ça a baissé d'ailleurs
partout en Europe et partout dans le
monde il y a un effet conjoncturel c'est
pas l'effet du du gouvernement mais ça
reste très élevé plus de 6 millions de
personnes qui son mattion tu as aussi
tout ce qui est emploi financé par
l'État les uber les uber Mach c'est
pareil tu as aussi le fait que il y a eu
une uberisation ça tu le retrouves par
exemple aux États-Unis où les
statistiques sont quand même beaucoup
plus détaillées donc tu peux travailler
un petit peu mieux et tu tu peux voir
que leurs chiffres sont aussi bidonnés
que les nôtres sinon plus et en fait le
le là aussi l'ubérisation a fait a fait
quelque chose c'est-à-dire que les
Américains se sont retrouver à avoir un
deux ou trois boulots d'accord sauf que
c'est un deux ou trois boulots à temps
partiel ou en tant
qu'uber quand tu arrêtes parce que tu tu
peux plus parce que tu n'es plus payé
assez parce que tu quittes un de tes
trois boulots
partiel tu rentres pas en chômage tu
n'es pas indemnisé donc tu ne rentres
pas dans les statistiques mais tu as
quand même perdu ton boulot il de
l'indemnisation aux États-Unis ah tu as
des indemnisations oui tu as des
indemnisations maintenant c'est beaucoup
plus court que nous c'est ça ça n' ça
n'a rien à voir mais il faut pour que tu
es un emploi salarié Salarié et pas
trois petits boulots
ok donc là on fait quoi on construit des
murs on durcit des lois on fait quoi en
sachant les fondamentaux qui se trouve
en face de
nous migration climatique migration de
guerre migration alimentaire migration
de catastrophe et gens passé des
meilleurs migration
économique migration peut-être de
certains pour survivre même pour la
plupart on fait quoi on construit des
murs il faut alors il y a pas construire
des murs mais il faut rétablir des
frontières nationales parce que comme je
le dis on peut même pas expulser les
gens peuvent revenir du jour au
lendemain s'il y a pas de frontières
nationale c'est complètement illusoire
en fait dans le cadre de l'Espace
Schengen de dire qu'on va lutter contre
l'immigration illégale donc pour le
volet immigration illégale ou pour tout
ce qui est expulsion il faut des
frontières nationales donc ça implique
de ne plus être dans Schengen après il y
a la problématique de l'immigration
légale qui est bien trop importante en
France il y a la composante du droit
d'asile pour vous pour être assimilé d'e
manè génér pour assimiler les gens pour
que ça fonctionne selon vous selon
l'expérience de la vie et selon selon
l'observation de la réalité ouais mais
ça ça vaut rien ça bah citez-moi un pays
où vous avez des une immigration massive
où ça se passe
bien j'en connais pas et et donc quand
quand vous avez ça c'est c'est
l'observation de de la de la réalité
après la problématique de l'immigration
légale il y a le droit d'asile qui a été
complètement dévoyé il faut savoir que
le droit d'asile avant en 1973 c'était
1600 personnes par an que c'était des
personnes connues on savait qu'il y
avait un problème elles étaient
identifiées maintenant vous aviez en
2022 156000 personnes qui ont demandé le
droit d'asile en France en 2023 les les
chif viennent de sortir ils estiment ça
va être entre 140 et 145000 personnes
par an mais en fait c'est plus du tout
un droit d'asile tel qu'on l'entend
d'ailleurs c'est très bien décrit par
Douglas Muray qui était quand il était à
Lesbos il explique très bien qu'en fait
c'est des gens qui arrivrive la plupart
ne vit pas de Syrie V pas d'Afghanistan
c'est des gens qui venaient d'Afrique et
en fait ils viennent pour de
l'immigration économique et après vous
avez vous avez tout un tas de système
aidés par les associations vous avez SOS
Méditerranée qui fait office de de taxis
de de migrant je peux pas vous laisser
dire ça ah si
non pas taxis il récup perd des pauvres
Gensou mais ça c'est très bien le le
sauvetage le sauvetage c'est très bien
et d'ailleurs c'est c'est c'est
honorable il faut évidemment sauver les
gens sauf que normalement faut les
ramener au port d'origine et là ce
qu'ils font c'est qu'ils vont les
chercher près des côtes et ils les
ramènent en Europe donc c'est pour que
je dis qu'ils font office de taxi
immigrants et derrière vous avez des
associations financé d'ailleurs par
notre argent du type France Terre
d'Asile 70 % de de subvention publique
qui derrière vont conseiller les
personnes au niveau du droit d'asile qui
vont leur dire les gens sans passeport
donc il disent qu' viennent de n'importe
quel pays dites que vous venez d'un pays
en guerre dites que vous êtesun minorité
oppressée dites que vous êtes homosexuel
pour passer le truc et même quand ils
sont de toute façon débou c'est quo vos
sources pour ça vous avez des enquêtes
celle de Douglas Muray il y en a
d'autres qui existent c'est c'est c'est
c'est c'est explicite dedans c'est les
associations qui sont là pour conseiller
pour qu'ils arrivent il y a eu des
reportages là-dessus de livre noir et
autres ils expliquent de qui de livre
noir qui a fait une enquête là-dessus
aussi sur comment fonctionne justement
le démarchage du droit d'asile ça marche
exactement comme ça et derrière quand
les gens sont débouttés avec le droit
européen ils peuvent rester en France je
rappelle quand même 150000 personnes par
an c'est équivalent de de Dijon anger et
CETA vous avez d'autres sources
d'information d'autres sour en fait
c'est le c'est leur job il revendique ça
leur ceux qui on enquété sur ce type
d'association Vous avez d'autres sources
non j'ai celle-ci mais comme c'est leur
leur travail ça m'étonne pas qu'il fasse
ça leur travail pour eux c'est de que le
maximum de migrants restent en France
mais tout ça pour vous dire leur travail
c'est de sauver ou d'assister des
personnes en souffrance ou issu de pays
en guerre ou issu de mais c'est c'est
c'est c'est c'est faux alors moi j'ai
une autre j'ai une autre source quand
j'avais fait mon truc sur la démographie
il y avait une autre source d'un de
alors j'ai j'ai pas le nom en tête je
suis désolé il faut que il faudrait que
je je je regarde sur mon sur mon papier
mais euh qui était qui travaillait en
Italie et qui avait fait un un énorme
rapport sur justement les migrants qui
arrivaient à Lampedusa et autres
euh et qui constaté qu'il avait fait des
tableaux donc c'était assez précis des
tableaux sur leur provenance et en fait
en effet il venait pas de pays en guerre
oua il venait pas de pays en guerre donc
c'était de la migration purement
économique et ça et ça c'est un vrai
problème parce que finalement c'est une
composante et moi je pense que
l'humanité en fait c'est tout le
contraire c'estd que j'ai du mal à
comprendre la position de la gauche à
l'heure actuelle parce que pour moi
l'humanité c'est si vous voulez
évidemment les noyades sont un DRAM mais
il faut sauver les gens des noyades
combien de mort en Méditerranée j'ai pas
le j'ai pas le chiffre exact je sais que
c'est c'est des chiffres importants mais
c'est-à-dire que c'est pas en
encourageant en faisant appel d'air en
disant vous pouvez venir que vous allez
empêcher les noyades en fait vous allez
augmenter les traversé vous allez
augmenter le nombre de noyades c'est
entant très ferme en ayant un
refoulement systématique en dissuadant
les traversées que vous n'aurez plus de
noyade et je veux dire il y a absolument
aucune humanité à faire venir des gens
dans des conditions lamentables qui
soient payé 3 franc 6 sous qui servent à
faire pression à la baisse sur les
salaires parce que les métiers tention
c'est ça en fait c'est faire venir des
esclaves des esclaves modernes pour
qu'ils viennent faire votre livraison
uber à vélo quand il fait quand il fait
froid pour qu'il vienneent travailler
faire la plonge pour 3 franc 6 sous
plutôt que de former les 6 millions de
chômeurs dont on parler de donner des
salaires décents en fait l'immigration
massive sert à faire pression à la
baisse sur les salaires et donc c'est
pour qu'il y a aucune humanité à faire
ça c'est tout le contraire et j'ajoute
qu'en plus ceux qui quittent leur pays
c'est pas des retraités c'est souvent
les forces vives de ces pays-là et ces
pays-là pour se développer ils auraient
besoin de leur forces viv c'est tout le
drame qu'on a vu lors de l'élargissement
de l'UE à l'Est où vous avez une saignée
démographique des pays de l'Est où
toutes les populations en âge de
travailler des pays de l'Est aller à
l'ouest parce que c'était mieux payé
est-ce que c'est un service à rendre à
ces pays-là évidemment que non donc en
fait il y a aucune unee humanité à
prenner l'immigration massive c'est même
le contraire donc il faudrait évidemment
faire un refoulement systématique et
arrêter le le le droit d'asile
normalement ça devrait être comme à
l'époque en 1973 1600 personnes par an
on devrait donner le droit d'asile à
Julian lassangeche par exemple quelqu'un
qui est identifié on sait qui pose pas
de problème et qui pour le coup devrait
avoir le droit d'asile mais c'est
n'importe quoi de d'accueillir 140000
personnes par an par le droit d'asile
après il y a l'autre dimension le
l'autre principal pourvoyeur
d'immigration légale c'est le
regroupement familial
or le regroupement familial s gravé dans
le marbre par une directive de l'UE qui
est la directive de 2003 qui fait que
avant les gens se disaient le
regroupement familial en fait c'est
giscar donc 74 dans les faits après il y
le décret de 76 sauf la grande
différence c'est quand c'était giscar
vous pouvez avoir un nouveau
gouvernement que vous lisiez et le
gouvernement pouvait dire bah ce
regroupement familial moi je l'arrête et
on passe à autre chose maintenant c'est
gravé dans le marbre au niveau de
l'Union européenne donc c'est pour ça en
fait que vous n'aurez pas de réduction
importante des flux d'immigration légal
tant que vous êtes dans le système de
l'Union européenne c'est pourquoi
d'ailleurs vous voyez mélonie qui qui a
été élu en fait sur la question de
l'immigration en fait l'immigration
illégale a doublé l'immigration légale
c'est exactement pareil ça ne bouge pas
et c'est la philosophie de l'Union
européenne qui même làdedans la
philosophie de l'Union européenne ce
n'est pas de dire on va dissuader les
migrants de venir il y a une déclaration
hier ou avanttière de la commissaire au
migration qui a dit que il fallait
accueillir un million d'immigrés légaux
en plus parant dans l'Union européenne
leur philosophie c'est plus
d'immigration j'en pour preuve le le
PACT sur l'immigration qui a été voté
qui est bien plus intéressant à lire que
la loi de Darmanin sur l'immigration ou
qui va être complètement d'ailleurs
vidée par par l'Union européenne et par
le Conseil constitutionnel ce pack
d'migration il dit quoi il dit que on va
pas arrêter l'immigration on va répartir
les migrants et si vous voulez pas c'est
20000 € par tête de PIP un pays comme la
France où on peut estimer que la clé de
répartition ce sera peut-être 100000
personnees par an ça veut dire que si
vous voulez pas vous payez 2 milliards
d'euros par
an donc ça se passe comme ça donc en
fait il faut et il y a des solutions
juridiques y a pour réduire les flux
migratoires mais en fait il il y a un
problème de de verrou juridique de
l'Union européenne et après il y a bien
sûr un problème de volonté politique on
l'a bien vu avec le Royaume-Uni qui est
sorti de de l'UE et qui pour le coup a
tous les outils juridiques pour baisser
l'immigration mais pourquoi ils le font
pas parce qu'il y a toute une frange du
Parti conservateur à la demande du
patronat anglais justement pour
maintenir la pression à la baisse sur
les salaires qui eux disent il faut
continuer de faire venir de
l'immigration au Royaume-Uni s'il y
avait quelqu'un par exle comme Nigel
Farage qui était au Royaume-Uni c'est
sûr que les flux migratoires vous
verriez une baisse drastique parce que
ils ont les outils juridiques le
Royaume-Uni étant libéré des règles de
l'Union européenne pour baisser les flux
migratoires s'ils le
veulent un commentaire de notre
communauté
15386 étrangers incarcéré en 2020 toute
nationalité confondue soit 23,6 % source
ministère de la Justice en baisse 23 % à
peu près au quart mais là c'est du 2020
ma source éit plus récente on était à
19000 18000 18900 en arrondiss et vot
source c'est qui c'est le ministère
c'est la même source en fait mais une
autre année
d'accord votre perception de l'énergie
le futur de l'énergie on en est où on va
faire quoi il faut s'attendre à quoi
alors vous n'êtes pas énergéticien non
vous intéressez à à ce facteur pour
ouais pour
anticiper pour anticiper les
mouvements Olivier l'énergie vous
attendez à quoi on VO je m'attends je
m'attends à des soucis puisque je
rappelle qu'en France on en a pas hein
des idées mais on a des idées je je suis
même plus sûr qu'on a tellement d'idées
mais bon même Bruno le ma euh même Bruno
et et grâce à Bruno bah en fait on grâce
à Bruno et à à à Manu on se on se fâche
avec tous les tous nos fournisseurs
d'énergie que ce soit l'Afrique que ce
soit la Russie que ce soit donc les
seuls les seuls avec qui on reste copain
c'est les États-Unis et eux se gavent
puisque ils nous vendent leur énergie
évidemment beaucoup beaucoup plus cher
donc en
fait il y a cette ce ce problème alors
les Allemands ont le même d'ailleurs he
puisque ils n'ont pas non plus d'énergie
et alors eux pas de chance ils ont
encore un embryon d'industrie euh euh
ils en ont de moins en moins mais enfin
ils ont quand même de l'industrie alors
nous on en a pas alors évidemment ça
nous pe c'est Bruno Bruno crie victoire
partout en disant que euh euh en disant
que
euh et bien on on on a consommer moins
d'énergie et il trouve que c'est c'est
vraiment une victoire si on consomme
moins d'énergie c'est que évidemment on
a moins d'industrie hein on est au même
niveau que la Grèce dans le PIB c'est
quand même frappant hein c'est pas on
est très très loin on est très très bas
pourquoi votre souff bah c'est les
chiffres c'est les chiffres de de
Eurostat Inc et cetera enfin bon c'est
gentil de demander la source à chaque
fois mais enfin c'est un peu c'est un
peu gavant on a des sources
croyez-le et qui sont bonnes donc euh
même si Raphaël en doute il se trouve
qu'on travaille et donc on on on
récupère des chiffres euh c'est notre
métier donc euh Raphaël qui dit mais en
quoi pardon
pour Raphaël qui dit mais en quoi il y a
un lien entre immigration et viol
causalité
pointexclamation c'est la causalité qui
est important la corrélation n'est pas
la
question ben en fait c'est c'est les
chiffres il a juste à les regarder euh
c'estàdire dire que si a si vous êtes
étranger il y a trois fois plus rapporté
à la population de viol d'étranger que
que de français en
France et c'est c'est ça vient de chif
en fait c'est les chifr du ministère
l'intérieur c'est les chiffres il a qu'
chercher comme visiblement c'est un
spécialiste
voilà on reprend sur l'énergie ou on
reste sur
Raphaël d'accord
donc oui alors le le en fait le problème
le problème c'est comme l'a
dit Charles
Henry le problème c'est que l' enfin le
PIB c'est de l'énergie transformée en
fait et que et que le fait d'avoir une
énergie pas chère pendant des années
nous avveit mis dans une situation qui
était plutôt intéressante vis-à-vis des
Allemands d'ailleurs qui rêvait que
d'une chose c'était de nous torpiller
là-dessus et mais et en fait grâce à à
Emmanuel et d'ailleurs à deux de ses
prédécesseurs il n'ont même pas eu à
nous
torpiller je rappelle
que Emmanuel Macron avant de nous parler
de des
futurs a fait fermer des centrales
nucléaires et
donc
les les réacteurs de dernière génération
et quand vous avez ce type
de de de de de volonté politique de
fermer des centrales nucléaires
qu'est-ce qui se passe bah il se passe
que vous perdez en fait le savoir-faire
pourquoi vous perdez le savoirfire parce
que évidemment les
étudiants ingénieurs futurs euh
futur employés de de de centrale
nucléaire et ben ils vont ailleurs
puisqu'ils savent qu'il y a pas de il y
a pas de débouché en France et donc on
est en train de perdre le savoir-faire
on est en
train élément d'industrie puisque je
rappelle quand même que
Emmanuel nous a vendu alstomin c'était
avant d'être président mais enfin il a
quand même joué un rôle majeur dans la
vente Alstom Alstom je vous rappelle que
c'était euh les les les turbines les
turbines et que euh euh et que
aujourd'hui bien on est euh on est
soumis au euh au bon vouloir des
Américains euh qui peuvent entretenir
nos centrales ou pas hein euh et donc on
est on est dans un dans quelque chose
qui euh avec le système de calcul
d'électricité avec et C tout ça c'est
des c'est un un un c'est
une une direction qui nous mène dans le
mur alors qu'on avait je le rappelle une
l'électricité la moins chère puisqu'on
avait du grâce au général de Gaulle on
avait lancé un programme nucléaire qui
avait fait qu'on avait entre les
centrales hydrauliques et le nucléaire
on avait une énergie qui était
réellement pas cher aujourd'hui j'ai
j'ai appris qu'on était en train de de
vendre des
barrages à cause de l'Europe qui demande
à ce qu'on vende des barrages donc c'est
pour ça qu'on invvestit pas d'ailleurs
dans le tout ça tout ça fait que on va
finir par payer le l'énergie beaucoup
plus cher que les autres et
malheureusement je pense que le la
réindustrialisation qu'appelle de ses
vux Bruno Le Maire elle va être aux
États-Unis et elle va pas être en France
pourquoi bah tout simplement parce que
un industriel ne peut pas se permettre
de payer deux fois ou trois fois ou
quatre fois plus cher que les autres son
électricité donc qu'est-ce qu'il va
faire et ben il va aller s'installer aux
États-Unis où il aura une électricité
bon marché voilà le le truc il est là
donc l'énergie aujourd'hui est un vrai
problème je rappelle que avec toutes les
bêtise qu'on a fait de se se précipiter
sur un truc qui est le le la voiture
électrique et le tout électrique et
cetera tout ça nous met entre les mains
de qui plus de l'EP mais de des Chinois
parce que on a besoin de terre RAR on a
besoin de de de métau RAR et cetera pour
faire les batteries et et autres et à ce
moment-là malheureusement c'est les
Chinois qui squattent 90% du marché donc
on va avoir des problèmes on va vraiment
avoir des problèmes j'ouvre une
parenthèse question internet pour
Charles Henry il pense sérieusement que
le problème est l'immigration et non pas
la pauvreté comment on fait avec la
pauvreté est-ce que c'est la pauvreté
qui crée des crimes des délits de la
délinquence est-ce que c'est
l'immigration c'est peut-être non je
suis pas aller dans la Nièvre ou dans la
Creuse il y a beaucoup de pauvreté
bizarrement il a moins de délinquence
donc c'estàd que c'est un tout il y a
pas un seul facteur évidemment que la
pauvreté y contribu mais les
statistiques parlent d'ell-même en fait
il y a même pas besoin de lui répondre
parce que je les ai donné il peut les
retrouver dans dans mon livre maintenant
sur la la question énergétique en fait
c'est un c'est un vrai drame parce que
cette crise énergétique avec le le
conflit ukraine-russie normalement la ça
aurait dû être l'apogé de l'histoire
électrique de la France et de l'histoire
du nucléaire de la France et la France
aurait dû être à ce moment-là une sorte
d'Arabie Saoudite de l'électricité qui
vendait à prix d'or l'électricité à ses
voisins sauf que le problème et c'est ce
qu' a commencé à évoquer Olivier c'est
qu'en fait ça fait 30 ans qu'on saccage
à la fois EDF qui était le premier
énergéticien mondial et qu'on saccage
notre industrie du nucléaire avec
évidemment à chaque fois l'Allemagne à
la manœuvre l'Union européenne avec une
complicité criminelle de nos dirigeants
parce qu'à chaque fois ils ont ils ont
signé les documents alors pour vous
c'est de la forfiture évidemment pour ce
qui est de pour ce qui est du du
nucléaire alors évidemment on pense
souvent à forfaiture ou de
l'incompétence je pense qu'il y a un peu
des deux il y a une part de de démagogie
je veux dire quand Lionel Jospin arrive
au au pouvoir en 97 suite à à la
victoire législative et qui fait
alliance avec ELV en se disant on va
fermer super Phenix il y a une part de
tambouille politicienne et de et de et
de de court vue c'est la même chose pour
Emmanuel Macron sur sur astri quand il
l'arrête en 2019 quel est l'argument
d'astri c'est de dire bah regardez le
cours de l'uranium il est il est faible
oui il est faible aujourd'hui il va être
comment dans 20 ans quand les autres
vont devoir aller avec des centrale
nucléaire il va être comment bah il va
il va évidemment augmenter le cours donc
on est dans une espè de de de courte vue
de démagogie c'est pareil Mel Macron il
est en son délire avec Nicolas hullo
Arnold charsenger make Planet great
again c'est formidable tout le monde est
beau tout le monde est gentil mais sauf
que c'est criminel parce que je rappelle
quand même que quand on parle de
nucléaire évidemment la France a un
approvisionnement avec les différents
pays Kazakhstan Australie et cetera
malgré le Niger on a quoi faire mais en
fait faut savoir que sur notre sol avec
l'uranium appauvri on a à peu près 31000
tonnes on pourrait faire fonctionner
avec des réacteur de 4e génération toute
la consommation d'énergie donc même
pétrole gaz et cetera annuel pendant
plus de 2000 ans donc en fait la clé
pour la souveraineté l'indépendance
énergétique de la France c'est le
nucléaire et c'est le nucléaire de 4e
génération donc avec les les fameux
réacteurs de à neutron rapide et ça ça a
été complètement saccagé par Lionel
Jospin François Hollande on avait 1 a 15
ans d'avance maintenant on a 10 ans de
retard sur les Chinois qui ont déjà
lancé deux centrales et euh non les
Chinois les Russes ont lancé deux pardon
et les Chinois on en lancé une fin 2021
et les États-Unis travaillent dessus
avec Bill Gates sur aussi un projet et
nous en fait on a complètement arrêté
alors queon était à la pointe sur le
sujet ça c'est absolument criminel il y
a le saccage même global du nucléaire
les gens pensent
à évidemment François Hollande avec la
fermeture de fen mais je rappelle que ça
a été confirmé par Emmanuel Macron il
pense à Fr and parce qu'il y avait ce
fameux projet de loi de fermer fahe
avait été entretenu oui il était en état
d'après l'Autorité de sûreté du
nucléaire d'après brcher vous a invité
tout un tas de de personnes y brch oui
et et et voilà mais ça c'est criminel
mais il y avait pas que ça en fait
dedans il y avait un projet de loi pour
fermer la moitié de nos réacteurs
nucléaires approuvé d'ailleurs par le
nouveau Premier ministre Gabriel Atal
qui était trouvé ça très bien lui
comment vous expliquez qu'ils aient
tourné leur cuti à vouloir faire plus de
réacteurs que que prévu maintenant alors
c'est là où on va avoir un problème on
va avoir un problème pourquoi parce que
il y a deux dimensions si on veut sortir
des énergies fossiles il faut
électrifier il faut plus de de réacteurs
même si on on passe tout le parc
automobile en voiture électrique au pic
de consommation typiquement au départ de
de vacances d'été il faudrait il
faudrait 10 à 15 réacteurs nucléaires de
plus que ce qu'on a leur projet de loi à
la base c'était 6 maintenant dans le
dernier j'ai vu qu' il pensit en mettre
8 le problème c'est qu'on va se heurter
aux règles de l'Union européenne
pourquoi parce qu' une directive qui est
pas très connue la directive sur les
énergies renouvelables qui explique qui
vient d'être voté la toute dernière on a
eu plusieurs je vais revenir dessus mais
la toute dernière explique à l'horizon
2030 c'estàdire demain il faudra que
42,5 % de la consommation d'énergie dans
les pays de l'Union européenne dont la
France soit des énergies renouvelables
c'est pour ça que la France milite pour
que le nucléaire soit considéré comme
une énergie renouvelable sauf que ce
n'est pas le cas ils ont réussi à le
passer dans la taxonomie qui le
financement qui a un autre problème pour
ce qui est de la consommation le
nucléaire n'est pas dans les énergies
renouvelables et c'estàdire que si vous
voulez arriver à 42,5 % de consommation
d'énergies renouvelable c'est impossible
de le faire en augmentant la part du
nucléaire c'est même l'inverse il faudra
baisser la part du nucléaire au profit
alors l'hydroélectrique on peut
augmenter un peu mais on le fait pas
parce que l'Union européenne force à la
privatisation des barrages donc DF se
dit bah si on me force à privatiser les
barrages je vais pas investir dedans
donc on en fait plus il reste l'éolien
et le solaire avec le problème de
l'intermittence qu'on connaît et on voit
bien le modèle allemand qui ne qui ne
fonctionne pas qui doit être euh secouru
par le le gaz et le charbon donc tout le
contraire d'une économie
décarbonée et donc il y a cette
problématique là qui va être énorme et
donc ça va être l'inverse en fait on ne
pourra pas investir dans le nucléaire on
va se heurter aux règles de l'Union
européenne et par ailleurs l'Union
européenne avec la complicité de nos
dirigeants a saccagé EDF je rappelle
queedf a une dette de 64,5 milliards
d'euros ça ne va pas aider à investir
massivement dans le nucléaire et comment
cette dette s'est constituée c'est dans
ce cadre de ce fameux marché de
l'électricité de l'Union européenne où
il y avait plusieurs principes il y
avait le fait de mise en concurrence
notamment et il y a aussi le problème du
mode de calcul des prix qui fait qu'en
fait on paye un prix fictif de
l'électricité à l'heure actuelle
l'électricité en fait on dit
schématiquement que le prix indexé sur
le gaz parce que c'est la dernière unité
de production mis en service qui est
souvent du gaz qui fixe le
prix c'est pour ça en fait que on n pas
un prix basé sur le mix et les coûts de
production qui en France serait bien
inférieur grâce au nucléaire et donc on
surpaye le prix de l'électricité c'est
pour ça que vos factures d'électricité
ont explosé et encore que on a été
soi-disant protégé par le bouclier
tarifaire mais qui n'est que de la dette
50 milliards d'euros mais pour les
entreprises c'est plein pot donc vous
avez des factures qu'on doublé qu'on
parfois triplé donc ça c'est c'est un
problème en tant que tel mais après il y
a un problème spécifique à EDF parce que
dans le délire de l'Union européenne de
vouloir mettre de la mise en concurrence
même quand vous avez un monopole naturel
comme EDF en fait il y a eu des
directives six à partir de 97 pour une
mise en concurrence de DF le problème
étant que personne pouvait arriver sur
le marché parce que personne n'était
rentable face à EDF et donc ces grands
technocrates de Bruxelles qu était quel
a été leur réaction c'està-dire bah on
va mettre en demeure la France parce
qu'il n'y a pas de concurrence donc la
France sinon va devoir payer des amendes
à l'époque c'était l'UMP sous Sarkozy
ils ont fait la loi Nome pour répondre à
ça la loi nom c'est la loi qui a mis en
place l'arène qui force DF à vendre 100
taw d'énergie nucléaire à des
concurrents fictifs à 42 € le MWh à
l'époque le coût enfin le prix moyen
était à 60 € le MWh c'est-à-dire que
vous allez donner 18 € le mgawh à des
gens qui font du trading qui ne
produisent pas 1 MWh d'électricité pas
eu d'investissement il y a rien il y a
pas eu d'investissement il surtout il y
a eu des pertes pour def la commission
énergie qui eu à l'Assemblée nationale
l'ancien PDG Henri plilieu explique que
ça a coûté la reine 3 à 4 milliards
d'euros par an EDF ce qui amène en plus
de problèmes de gestion par ailleurs la
dette actuelle deedf et donc ça c'est un
problème énorme et ça ça a saccagé
complètement en fait EDF cette mise en
concurrence fictive vous avez des des
concurrents parasitaires vous avez un
prix de l'électricité qui est
complètement décorrélé de la réalité et
donc vous avez un système qui ne marche
pas et un système qui nuit profondément
en fait aux intérêts de la France et nos
gouvernements qui ont accepté ça et qui
continuent de le faire parce que là le
bouclier t faire 50 milliards d'euros
c'est pas dans les traités hein le le
mode de calcul du prix de l'électricité
autant la mise en concurrence ça c'est
très difficile en restant dans l'Union
européenne parce que c'est gravé dans le
marque des traités mais le prix de
l'électricité dans aucun traité on
aurait très bien pu dire à partir de
2021 plutôt que de dépenser 50 milliards
d'euros c'est le le budget de la défense
hein le coût de construction de 446
hôpitaux on aurait pu dire
jeauraisétablis un prix national de
l'électricité basé sur notre coût moyen
de production avec une marge évidemment
pour EDF pour qu'il puisse faire du
profit investir dans l'avenir mais qui
aurait été bien moins cher que le prix
actuel et de dire très bien pour le prix
de marché européen on garde le Prix
européen ce qui nous arrange parce que à
part en 2022 la France est
traditionnellement exportatrice et donc
ça nous arrange d'exporter à prix d'or
mais en fait nos dirigeants par
dogmatisme dogmatisme une sorte de
dogmatisme religieux pour l'Union
européenne par manque de courage n'ont
pas souhaité faire ça et ça c'est c'est
criminel quand on voit les défaillances
d'entreprise quand on voit la la
problématique sociale aussi tout un tas
de personnes enfin les factures
d'électricité en un an pour les
particuliers malgré les tarif réglementé
que bruxelles veut faire sauter je
l'explique dans dans mon livre avec une
directive et bien ça a augmenté de 31 %
en un an quand vous avez par ailleurs
une inflation alimentaire qui était
maintenant qui est retombaéit à 7 mais
qui étaé à un moment à plus de 10 % mais
les gens qui qui qui ont des bass
salaires vous pouvez plus joindre les
debout c'est pas possibleite c'est
chiffres gentil parce que nous nous les
calculs qu'on a fait sur notre propre
facture les chifffres son plus non mais
je les chiffres officiels parce que vous
voulez les sources ce ce qu'il faut ce
qu'il faut dire c'est que que on était
arrivé quand même à cette aberration au
pic du du prix de l'électricité au pic
du prix de l'électricité il y avait des
moments où
EDF était obligé d'acheter sur le marché
oui c'est-à-dire à 300 400 500 et
CETA était obligé d'acheter sur le
marché pour donner à ses concurrents qui
sont des concurrents totalement
artificiels c'est c'est il y a ils ne
font rien d'accord pour le pour leur
refiler à 40
balles que eux
revendent aussi une part sur le marché
c'est enfin on crée de la perte pour
rire enfin c'est juste je sais pas si ça
a amusé Bruno Le Maire mais il a il a
quand même maintenu cette ce système
alors même que l'Espagne et le Portugal
sortait de ce système ils sont sortis
très ridement al c'est plus compliqué
ils sont pas vraiment sortis ce qu' fait
ils ont subventionné le prix du gaz ce
qui contrairement au bouclier tarifaire
avait l'avantage comme j'explique c'est
indexé sur le prix du gaz de baisser le
prix à la fois pour les particuliers et
pour les les professionnels mais mais en
soit c'est c'est quand même c'est quand
même de l'argent public alors qu'on
pourrait très bien sortir du mode de
calcul tu peux sortir du mode de calcul
et alors ce qui est fou c'est que Bruno
Le Maire répond à ça ah bah non on peut
pas sortir pourquoi on peut pas sortir
je veux dire du jour au lendemain on
pouvait dire on abandonne ce système de
terminé et ce qui il y a un autre
mensonge là-dessus c'est quand on nous
dit attention si vous sortez du marché
de l'électricité de l'Union européenne
vous n'aurez plus d'interconnextion si
vous en avez besoin mais ça c'est une
fumisterie sans nom je veux dire la
Suisse interconnecté la Suisse n'est pas
dans le marché d'électricité de l'Union
européenne donc ça c'est un argument
tétanisant qui qui ne vaut pas qui ne
qui ne reflète pas la réalité d'ailleurs
c'est la même chose le Royaume-Uni n'est
plus dans le marchééectricité de l'Union
européenne et interconnecté avec les
autres donc ça n'empêche pas du tout les
interconnexions on peut avoir un prix
national et échanger à ce prix de de
marcher qui est défini alors j'ouvre une
parenthèse on rend bobine sur le sujet
précédent
euh votre invité qui dit qu'il ne peut
pas avoir que qu'il ne peut pouvoir
voilà c'est mal formulé votre invité dit
qu'il ne va pas pouvoir accueillir plus
de quelques milliers de personnes quit
des millions de déplacés climatiques je
le rassure c'est pas nous qui
accueillons d'ailleurs on peut lui on
pourrait peut-être lui demander s'il
veut accueillir quelqu'un des des des
millions de
déplacésensite
commentaire si c'est pour dérouler du
programme de l'extrême droite c'est pas
de l'analyse c'est de la
politique toute façon dès qu'ils
comprennent pas il te il
teur un droit inconditionnel étranger ou
non les clandestins n'ont aucun droit
spécifique non les allocations c'est
vrai que c'est pas un droit spécifique
alors non mais en fait ce truc de
l'extrême droite je veux dire y a rien
d'extrême droite George marché jeures
tenait exactement le même discours sur
les mration massive sur la pression à la
baisse sur les salaires c'est vraiment
l'argument Massu quand on a pas
d'argument en réalité je parle de fait
je parle de chiffr il y a même pas de de
jugement de valeur encore une fois
l'immigré en tant que en tant
qu'individu évidemment qui cherche une
vie meilleur je parle du problème de
système de l'immigration massive moi je
je ne vise jamais l'immigrer en tant
qu'individu je je vise le système
d'immigration massive et je veux dire ce
n'est pas à la France la France a déjà
pris largement sa part depuis des années
c'est pas à la France d'accueillir ces
gens-là pour éviter encore une fois les
déplacements il faut fixer les
populations je sais par exemple que la
Russie a un programme d'une centrale
nucléaire en Afrique c'est c'est très
bien il faut une énergie abondante et
bon marché pour développer les les pays
africains mais les pays africains ça
fait des années qu'il sont indépendants
comme les pays asiatiques au bout d'un
moment on peut pas les remplacer non
plus c'est à eux de faire leur travail
c'est à eux de se développer on peut les
aider mais c'est pas parce qu'il y a une
un problème de développement que la
France doit accueillir tous les
ressortissants de ces
pays-là il y a il y a deux il y a deux
choses d'abord malheureusement je
rappelle qu'on est toujours soumis au
dictat de de l'Europe et Europe qui joue
à la à la même chose
avec quand elle te dit que elle veut
intégrer l'Ukraine par exemple en
l'Ukraine je rappelle que le le salaire
le salaire moyen en Ukraine c'est 200
dollars le mois c'est ça oui c'est un
minimum sur € euh donc évidemment ça
veut dire quoi bah ça veut dire que tu
vas te retrouver avec un pays dans
lequel le salaire est à 200 et qui va
forcément peser sur les les salaires des
Français des Allemands et cetera quand
ils vont euh intégrer ce ce pays dans le
dans l'Europe donc c'est une volonté
c'est une volonté des des politiques
c'est une volonté des Européens qui se
foutent complètement de ces peuples-là
c'est pas le sujet pour
euxécion aussi le sujet aujourd'hui pour
eux c'est pas c'est pas d'aller sauver
les gens qui vont se noyer dans la mer
et cetera crois-moi ils s'en foutent
complètement le sujet pour eux c'est de
c'est de baisser et c'est de mettre un
un un un
couvercle sur les les salaires c'est
tout et j'ai une question le reste le
reste les intéresse pas et si on
interdisait l'évasion fiscale que le
fric de l'évasion fiscale on l'utilisait
pour mieux accueillir mieux formmer
mieux héberger construire des choses
pour essayer d'avancer c'est combien
l'évasion fiscale en France c'est estimé
entre 80 et 100 milliards mais pour moi
c'est deux sujets fait 80 et 100
milliards de sujets jet indépendance
c'est pas qu'une question de de moyens
c'est une question de de nombre et de
possibilités d'assimiler encore une fois
on assimile des individus des minorités
on n'assimile jamais des peuples et si
vous mettez demain 4 million de Français
au Mexique ils vont pas s'assimiler hein
ils vont vivre entre eux ils vont vivre
la française c'est une question de
nombre alors c'est pour moi c'est deux
sujets qui sont séparés alors évidemment
que c'est plus simple d'intégrer
d'assimiler quand on est en plein emploi
quand il y a plus de moyens quand il y a
aussi une éducation nationale qui marche
et qui arrête de cracher sur la France
en permanence et qui quinculle plutôt
une certaine
fierté que vous avez vu que l'éducation
nationale crachait sur la France bah
regardez les programmes d'histoire on
peut pas
dire France l'étranger on peut pas dire
que les programmes d'histoire mettent
l'accent sur les grands personnages de
l'histoire de France les périodes
glorieuses de l'histoire de France on
vous explique jamais les quel quel
programme c'était déjà le cas à mon
époque et visiblement ça s'est dégradé
c'est-à-dire que Napoléon fait une
demi-journée François 1 vous faites
peut-être une demi-journée par contre la
collaboration ça on vous en parler
pendant des semaines on va pas vous
expliquer que c'est lors de la première
guerre mondiale c'est la France qui a
tenu à bout de bras seul et c'est la
France qui a le plus grand effort de
guerre qui l'a gagné on va pas vous
expliquer qu'il y avait près de 600000
français de la France Libre qu'on
participer à la libération de la France
pour la deuxième guerre mondiale en fait
tout ceci moi je l'ai appris dans des
livres en lisant de mon côté je l'ai
jamais appris à l'école et c'est sûr que
c'est pas en masquant la période
glorieuse de l'histoire de France qu'on
va donner envie à des jeunes d'ailleurs
français issu de l'immigration ou non
d'être d'être fier d'être français ça
c'est un véritable c'est un véritable
c'est un véritable problème aussi la
l'éducation nationale d'une mare
générale et donc en fait évidemment
qu'il y a tout un tas d'autres facteurs
qui expliquent que c'est plus difficile
d'intégrer mais il nen reste pas moins
qu'au bout en fin de compte il y a une
question de nombre vous pouvez mettre
tous les moyens que vous voulez dans les
conditions je veux dire la Suède c'est
pas le la Suède c'est pas la c'est pas
la c'est pas la Guyana et et même la
Suède a pas pu intégrer 2 millions de
personnes sur une population de de de 8
millions à la base c'est une question de
nombre encore une fois on intègre des
individus des minorités on n inègre pas
et on assimile pas des peuples entiers
revenons à l'énergie euh donc il faut
faire
quoi déjà il faut attends il faut faire
quoi pour aller où et
comment
déjà peut-être arrêter de faire les les
les les imbéciles avec
avec ce qu'on fait alors qu'on va à mon
avis lourdement payer hein euh c'est ce
qu'on fait vis-à-vis de la Russie euh
c'est c'est obéir aux États-Unis c'est
on pas un autre pays oui d'accord et et
euh enfin je vais pas je vais pas
reparler là-dessus je me suis
suffisamment exprimé là-dessus mais
excuse-moi mais le le c'est un c'est un
total montage américain depuis le début
le l'histoire ukrainienne donc et et ils
ont fait tout ce qu'il fallait pour nous
couler et il ils ont réussi ils ont
réussi c'est c'est mon c'est mon c'est
mon prisme et et je l'assume et même si
Raphaël n'est pas content
donc donc le le le c'est une opération
montée par les Américains qui
depuis quand même 40 ans foutent le
bordel dans absolument tous les pays du
monde et contrairement à la Russie qui
n'a pas de base en dehors de de de ces
de son pays il nous ont quand même aidé
à se faire dégager d'Afrique les Russes
non non je c qu'on s'est dégagé tout
seul tu sais ça fait ça fait très
longtemps que que Macron se se fout de
la gueule des des des présidents
africains ça fait très longtemps que il
les considère comme des moins que rien
euh
euh ça a été filmé donc on a là aussi il
y a des sources tu vois hisire
l'histoire de la
climatisation ouais bon donc quand on se
fout de la gueule des gens au bout d'un
moment ça peut les énerver hein donc que
ils ont absolument pas besoin des Russes
pour nous dehors ça fait
longtemps qu'avec le franç FAA on se on
se permet de piller les pays
africains et qu'on fait en sorte alors à
part quelques présidents qui en
bénéficient largement de la corruption
et pas malheureusement leur leur
population
mais on a tout fait pour les maintenir
en fait dans le dans le le le le dans
une crise économique
perpétuelle il c'est il y a un moyen
très simple en fait pour que le
l'Afrique décle le problème aujourd'hui
c'est que en Afrique on donne beaucoup
de sous qui arrive ben je vais je je je
développe il y a un moyen très simple de
de de faire en sorte que il se développe
parce que je sais pas si tu as remarqué
mais enfin ça fait quand même des années
et des
années
paye en général un peu en dessous de de
ce que on devrait les payer sur les
marchés mais le problème il est pas là
le problème c'est qu'en fait ils n'ont
aucune industrie de transformation donc
en fait la valeur ajoutée c'est chez
nous qu'on l'a fait donc on leur prend
leurs matières premières qu'on leur
achète d'accord qu'on leur achète un peu
moins cher je te dis que sur les marchés
mais qu'on le achète quand même mais le
problème c'est qu'il y a pas de valeur
ajoutée et donc la valeur ajoutée ne
reste pas dans le pays la valeur ajoutée
elle est faite ailleurs elle est faite
dans les pays occidentaux qui prennent
les matières premières qui les emmènent
chez eux qui font qui en font des
produits tant que tu n'auras pas
d'industrie de transformation sur place
et donc une valeur ajoutée qui restera
sur place tu n'auras aucun développement
tu peux mettre des milliards tu n'auras
aucun développement donc c'est voulu et
c'est voulu par nos pays depuis très
longtemps tant qu'on tant qu'on
continuera à fonctionner comme ça et
bien l'Afrique ne se développera pas et
à ce moment-là qu'est-ce qui va se
passer bah il va se passer que le mieux
disant c'est-à-dire aujourd'hui
probablement le chinois le mieux disant
va continuer à s'installer en Afrique et
et nous qui avons plus les moyens qu'on
avait avant pour corrompre les
dirigeants africains et bien on va se
faire on va se faire lourder et c'est ce
qui est en train de se passer et tu vois
il y a pas besoin des Russes pour
ça alors il y a il y a plusieurs choses
dans ce qu'Olivier a dit on en revient
pour faire la transformation il faut de
l'énergie donc on en revient au au au
sujet fondamental de de l'énergie aussi
abondante et et bon marché après il y a
la question effectivement des des
sanctions vis-à-vis de la Russie moi je
pense que ça fait surtout mal à
l'Allemagne avec un mix énergétique et
très dépendante du gaz la France
normalement à part pour certains
secteurs très spécifiques industriels
aurait dû être moins touché notamment
grâce à ce à son parc nucléaire et c'est
là toute la problématique du nucléaire
alors il y a les fertilisant il y a
machin voilà c'est ou je dis il y a des
point spécif c'est au-delà de c'est
au-delà du pétrole et du gaz hein le
problème aussi c'est une sorte
d'inconséquence de nos dirigeants
c'estàd c'est typiquement les sanctions
vis-à-vis de la Russie des sanctions qui
sont prises sans jamais mesurer les
conséquences quand vous avez quelqu'un
comme Bruno Lemire qui vous explique
qu'il allait mettre à genou l'économie
russe mais moi il m'amuse en Bruno Lemer
il a jamais mis quelqu'un à genou dans
sa vie à part dans ses romans en fait et
là le problème c'est le problème c'est
qu'il a en train de mettre à genou
malheureusementon disait les entreprises
françaises qui vont être en défaillance
il train de mettre à genou les
particuliers français ceux qui arrivent
plus à se chauffer ceux qui arrivent
plus à manger ceux qui AR plus à faire
quoi avec les les Ukrainiens il fallait
laisser se faire dépouiller il fallait
ah non non moi je je dis pas ça moi je
suis pour la la souver une force
d'interposition malgré les menaces de
force nucléaire il fallait faire quoi il
fallait fallait déjà fallait il fallait
il fallait les accords de Budapest
fallait les respecter aussi il fallait
un plan de paix il fallait un plan de
paix et je veux dire les sanctions
contre la Russie n'ont pas servi à
grand-chose le le problème étant que
évidemment moi je suis pour le le
respect de la la souveraineté
territoriale et Don la souveraineté
territoriale ukrainienne le problème
c'est que en Ukraine effectivement il y
a eu des jeux de déstabilisation
notamment à l'est du pays de la part des
États-Unis c'est ce qu' a dit ce qu' a
dit Olivier je pense que Poutine a fait
une erreur stratégique en attaquant le
le premier quelque part parce qu'il
apparaît comme l'agresseur mais
évidemment que cette agression elle est
condamnable mais il y a il y a tout un
toute une histoire avant ça de
provocation je rappelle quand même qu'il
y avait un gouvernement qui était élu
qui a été renversé alors on nous dit que
c'est une révolution quand c'est le camp
du Bien sinon c'est un coup d'état bon
ça dépend un petit peu du point de vue
qu'on du point de vue qu'on prend je
rappelle après qu'il y a une une sorte
de guerre civile avec les populations
russophones à l'est de l'Ukraine qui
étit bombardé donc c'est plus compliqué
que le gentil et le méchant c'est-à-dire
que là-dedans moi je pense avant tout
piqu la en 2014 non oui oui c'est vrai
et je je dis pas le contraire en réalité
ce que je dis juste c'est qu'il y a pas
de gentil il y a pas de méchant dans
cette histoire c'est c'est c'est juste
ça et que la France en fait on rentre
dans une espèce de géopolitique à
l'américaine du gentil contre le méchant
alors normalement géopolitique c'est ce
que disait le le général de Gaulle en
fait un état il a pas d'amis il a que
des intérêts et on a l'impression d'une
sorte de géopolitique à l'émotion avec
le le gentil et le méchant mais en fait
quand on fait ça à quel moment on défend
les intérêts de la France à quel moment
dans le conflit Russie Ukraine la France
a défendu ses
intérêts à quel moment quand il y avait
le problème en Libye en Syrie la France
défendait ses intérêts en fait la France
ne défend plus ses intérêts on est dans
une sorte de magma Union européenne
autant et on s'aligne à chaque fois sur
la vision géopolitique des autres mais
la France n'a plus une voix propre
dans le monde et elle ne défend plus ses
intérêts mais ce qui n'est pas étonnant
en fait parce que ça va de perd pour moi
avec la perte de souveraineté parce que
quand vous n'avez plus votre
souveraineté en fait normalement la la
la la diplomatie ce n'est que la défense
des intérêts la défense de la
souveraineté quand vous n'avez plus de
souveraineté en fait qu'est-ce que vous
défendez bah rien donc vous êtes dans
une sorte de de géopolitique de
l'émotion puis vous vous alignez sur le
plus fort dans une géopolitique de
cowboy avec le le camp du Bien le camp
du mal les gentils les méchants et donc
on est en plein là-dedans mais mais ça
c'est dramatique parce que je pense que
la France a une
vocation historique et c'était porté par
le Général de Gaule c'estàd évidemment
qu'au niveau des valeurs on est plus
proche du camp occidental mais faut pas
non plus être complètement stupide et
quand on regarde qui détient les
matières premières qui détient la
production c'est plus du côté des des
bricks que que du côté des des pays
occidentaux donc si la France est un T
soit peu intelligente
certes on est plus proche des valeurs
occidentales mais on serait au milieu un
État indépendant qui chercherait à faire
le pont en fait entre les deux et une
sorte de troisème voie la troème voix
goliste comme ce qui a toujours été le
rôle de la France mais là on s'enfonce
dans un rôle en fait de de caniche
complet de l'utant ce qui n'a pas de
sens tant pour les intérêts français que
tant pour la vocation historique de la
France et ça je pense que c'est
dramatique on fait quoi selon
vous la
serait serait de de de sortir de de
l'Europe alors je vais en faire bondir
beaucoup
mais parce que dès qu'on parle de ça on
est traité de fasciste
mais en effet il faudrait qu'on récupère
d'abord notre souveraineté et pour
récupérer notre souveraineté il y a pas
il y a pas de choix il faut sortir de de
l'Europe pour moi l'Europe c'est un
système mafieux c'est pas un système
démocratique c'est un système mafieux où
il y a une commission européenne avec à
sa tête une une femme qui s'appelle van
derleyen van derleyen qui a été virée
pour corruption du ministère de la
Défense
allemand quand même s'en souvenir qui
trempe dans des affaires avec le le le
le le vaccin
Pfizer affaires les affaires des SMS
publ de son de son de son mari ou
paxé ou ou Aman j'en sais rien mais
enfin son le le type avec qui lui qui
curieusement d'être un peu plus précis
non non après demande à Raphaël de
vérifier
euh
donc avec des affaires de corruption au
fesses qui sont qui sont énormes
et et si tu ne sors pas de ce ce carcan
ben en fait tu peux rien faire c'est
bien le problème d'ailleurs aujourd'hui
c'est-à-dire que tu peux changer de de
Premier ministre tu peux même changer de
président du moment que tu restes dans
l'Europe en fait il faut quand même
savoir que l'essentiel de nos lois sont
des lois qui sont européennes
l'essentiel des directives des des des
enfin de ce qu'on fait sur les retraite
et cetera c'est demandé par qui c'est
demandé par l'Europe donc tout ça fait
que tu ne sors pas de l'Europe tu ne
récupères pas donc ta ta tu tu ne
récupères pas ta liberté de de légiférer
et ta liberté d'action et à ce moment-là
bah tu peux mettre qui tu veux tu peux
faire ce que tu veux tu peux demander à
faire ce que tu veux au final c'est
l'Europe qui décide donc tant que tu
n'as pas récupéré ta souveraineté je
dirais tout le reste est de la de la
discussion et de la communication
question pour Charles hen en Espagne
quand la lo immigration est passée elle
a été acclamée par le président de Vox
un parti franquiste monsieur Gallois
vous dites qu'un peuple immigrant ne
peut pas s'assimiler en France
pointinrogation c'est pas que j'ai tout
sortez-vous cela avez-vous vécu à
l'étranger monsieur Gallois pour être
aussi sûr de ce que vous dites alors oui
j'ai vécu à l'étranger j'ai vécu en
Espagne en Suisse je pense qu'il a pas
bien compris ce que j'ai dit j'ai pas
dit que des immigrés ne pouvaient pas
s'assimiler au contraire ça a été montré
d'ailleurs de toute origine
qui se sont assimilés en France pendant
des années il y en a encore certains qui
arrivent à s'assimiler je dis juste que
quand vous faites une immigration
massive il est impossible d'assimiler ne
serait-ce que la majorité des gens qui
arrivent parce que c'est une question de
nombre maintenant que le le type de de
Vox est acclamé la loi immigration je
pense que il a pas bien regardé ce qu'il
y avait dedans parce que les deux choses
qui sont intéressante c'est de rétablir
le délit de séjour irrégulier justement
donc de pouvoir incarc ser pour pouvoir
expulser bah ça en fait ça va être ça va
aller à l'encontre de la directive
retour donc ça va être retoqué soit par
l'UE soit par le Conseil constitutionnel
et l'autre c'est de d'expulser les
étrangers délinquants super sauf que
comme je l'ai dit comme on est dans
Schengen ils peuvent revenir du jour au
lendemain donc ce qui va rester de cette
loi c'est au contraire de la
régularisation de clandestin et donc un
appel d'air pour faire pression à la
baisse sur les salaires donc en fait moi
je j'appelle ça une une loi qui va
encore augmenter augmenter au contraire
l'immigration donc bon il peut applaudir
soit soit il a pas compris soit il
connaît pas le le sujet notre ser je
vous mets dans un Rapp je vous mets dans
le scénario suivant euh donc le GC nous
dit que il y a des zones qui vont être
inhabitables dû à l'augmentation de la
température auutau d'humidité donc on va
se taper dans des parties du monde des
zones très déjà très peuplées qui vont
devenir inhabitabl avec des gens qui
vont bouger pour éviter de canner à
l'extérieur de chez eux euh euh ils
n'ont pas l'énergie pour pouvoir se
refroidir euh donc ils vont être obligés
d'aller chercher un peu plus loin euh
euh des condition
viable bien entendu ça va créer des
déstabilisations si on suit le scénario
donc des déstabilisations de compte de
de de pays donc des des potentiels
guerre des potentiels guerr civiles des
potentiels euh euh euh
euh pénurie alimentaire ou des problèmes
de rendement alimentaire une
augmentation des prix alimentaires et on
en passe et on en passe et on en passe
dans ce contexte là est-ce que vous
pensez que la France avec ses tout
petits bras si elle commence à avoir une
politique protectionniste à se
recroviller sur elle-même est-ce qu'elle
va pouvoir gérer est-ce que par exemple
je prends un exemple quand il y a des
feux chez nous que nos copains européens
nous prêtent des canadir ou inversement
c'est peut-être bien ça aussi non par ça
n'existait pas avant l'union européenne
ça donc est-ce que la France avec ses
petits bras va pouvoir selon les
vagues de de catastrophe qu'on nous
annonce pouvoir faire quelque chose
toute seule avec ses petits bras alors
qu'on a une industrie qui est en train
de se se casser la figure que les
Français n'ont plus confiance on a une
industrie pourquoi elle se casse la
figure pourquoi se casse-t-elle la
figure parce que on a on a je vous
laisserai répondre dans
ça on va dire que les plans à long terme
c'est c'est plus à l'ordre du jour donc
comment on
fait avec un un un Biotop qui va pouvoir
se résumer par chacun son cul et Dieu
pour tous alors je vais répondre à ça
déjà moi je fais toujours la distinction
entre Europe qui est un continent au
mieux une civilisation et Union
européenne qui est qui est une mafia qui
est surtout une organisation politique
supra supranationale selon vous la mafia
ou oui une organisation une organisation
poque une organisation politique
supranationale disons on va dire l' une
organisation politique supranationale
qu'est-ce que c'est c'est de
dire sur tous les sujets même quand vous
avez des intérêts divergents vous allez
suivre la même politique ce qui est
complètement stupide et qui est entre
nous soit dit l'inverse de ce qu'a fait
la richesse de de l'Europe qui était la
diversité avec des modèles différents on
prenait une part du modèle qui
réussissait en fait le modèle qu'on suit
de l'Union européenne c'est l'inverse de
ce qui fonctionne dans le monde et c'est
en fait si vous le modèle qui est qui
est défini pour les 27 c'est le mauvais
ce qui le cas l'heure actuelle vous avez
tout le monde qui va droit dans le mur
donc c'est c'est super intelligent c'est
un peu comme si vous mettiez tous vos
investissements dans le même panier
c'est aussi intelligent que ça l'Union
européenne mais après vous pouvez très
bien avoir de la ce qu'on appelle de la
coopération internationale la
coopération internationale c'est quoi
c'est exactement ce que vous évoquez je
veux dire il y avait des échanges de
Canadair il y avait des interconnexions
d'énergie il y avait des échanges
universitaires avant l'apparition de
l'Union européenne et de Saint-Jacques
delur ça ça existait tout ça avant et la
coopération internationale qui qu'est-ce
que c'est c'est quand même plus
intelligent
que une organisation politique
supramnationale c'est de dire à
quelquesuns 4 5 si sur les domaines
uniquement où on a les mêmes intérêts là
on va travailler ensemble parce que je
les la Suisse n'est pas dans l'Union
Européenne la Suisse n'est pas un pays
Olivier pour en parler qui est isolé du
monde qui est une sorte de de Corée du
Nord ça n'existe pas ça n'existe pas un
pays qui VI en autarci c'est-à-dire que
vous pouvez très bien c'est finalement
ce qu'on appelle l'Europe des nations
passer du une Union européenne
supranationale et une Europe des nations
qui est une Europe de coopération
internationale à la carte si bah
évidemment sur le nucléaire on va pas
travailler avec les Allemands mais on
peut travailler avec les pays de l'Est
on peut travailler avec l'Italie on peut
travailler avec la Finlande sur le
l'agriculture on peut travailler avec
l'Espagne on peut travailler avec
l'Italie en fait on peut faire de la
coopération internationale et ça c'est
très intelligent je veux dire les deux
seuls exemples qu'on nous cite pour
l'Union européenne c'est herbus et Arian
mais en fait herbus et Arian la
Commission européenne n'a jamais mis son
nez dedans c'est justement la
coopération internationale c'est de la
coopération interétatique et d'ailleurs
dans les deux vous avez des pays qui ne
sont même pas européens parce qu'on peut
faire de la coopération internationale
hors du périmètre de de l'Europe en fait
il y a pas que l'Europe dans le monde je
rappelle quand même que la France grâce
à ses autres mèes est présente sur les
cinq continents en fait il y a il y a un
horizon hors de l'Europe et je veux dire
le monde évolue et bouge hors de
l'Europe donc la France peut faire de la
coopération internationale bien
évidemment naturellement avec nos
voisins mais pas que pourquoi se limiter
à ça en fait et c'est ça toute la
problématique du projet Union européenne
qui a un projet au final rétrograde
assez vieux jeux et qui ne marche pas je
veux dire quand on voit les les deux
derniers arguments pour défendre le
projet européen c'est de dire regardez
grâce à l'euro vous avez pas changer
votre monnaie quand vous changez de
frontière et regardez Erasmus comme si
on avait pas d'échang feu Franck
bianquerie voilà comme si on avait pas
de d'échange universitaire avant l'union
européenne comme si ça se limitait au
périmètre de l'UE c'est vrai que les
jeunes il y en a aucun qui vont en
Australie aux États-Unis en fait Erasmus
faut se réveiller c'est c'est une bourse
hein les anglais sont sortis de l'Union
européenne ils ont créé une autre bourse
qui s'appelle Turing et ils financent
comme ça et pour ce et pour ce qui est
de changer de l'argent quand même ça
c'est le sketch ça montre bien la
mentalité des partisans de l'EU qui sont
restés bloqués au 20e siècle
c'est-à-dire qu'entre tempemps il y a
une formidable invention qui s'appelle
la carte de crédit et regardez c'est
magique vous pouvez aller à Genève vous
pouvez aller à Londres vous allez dans
un bar et vous payez avec votre carte de
crédit ça vous avez plus besoin d'aller
à la Banque de France de changer vos
billets et cetera donc en fait c'est des
gens qui sont restés et qui ont des
arguments à part deun projet de la peur
de dire si vous sortez ça va être la
catastrophe ils n'ont aucun argument
rationnel pour défendre leur projet
d'Union Européenne parce que ça ne
marche pas et tous les résultats
économiques et autres montrent au
contraire un déclin des pays membres de
l'UE question internet l'Angleterre ne
décline-t-elle pas beaucoup plus vite
que la France depuis son brexit c'est
pas vrai tous les chiffres économique en
fait monte l'inverse j'ai j'ai fait une
émission là-dessus récemment vous prenez
le taux de chômage il est inférieur au
runi le taux d'emploi il est supérieur
la croissance depuis le brexit je veux
dire le Royaume-Uni a récupéré le niveau
de PIB d'avant covid avant l'Allemagne
avant la France avant la zone euro donc
c'est absolument faux le Royaume-Uni a
des difficultés parce que on est en
périodre de crise parce qu'ils ont fait
aussi des erreurs parils sont dirig oui
par des ils ont fait des erreurs qui
n'ont rien à voir avec le brexit quand
ils ont fait de la création monétaire
qui amené inflation c'est ce qu' a fait
la B ça rien à voir avec le brexit le
fait qu'ils ont fait les sanctions
contre la Russie et qu'en plus ils ont
le le manque de chance d'avoir un mix
énergétique qui est très dépendant du
gaz mais ça se mix énergétique c'est pas
le brexit qu'il a créé il existait avant
et il y a un autre problème très
spécifique au Royaume-Uni qui existe
d'ailleurs dans des pays de l'Union
européenne c'est que eux ils ont des
taux d'intérêt qui sont variables un peu
comme la bourde de notre ami Bruno
Lemire qui a fait des emprunts d'exè
surinflation et bien c'est-à-dire que
quand il y a l'inflation bah la Banque
d'Angleterre a monter ses taux et et ben
forcément au niveau du pouvoir d'achat
imaginez votre votre appartement que
vous avez acheté si vos taux sont
variables bah vous avez des mensualités
qui explosent et donc ça met en
difficulté évidemment les Britanniques
mais ça ce système de taux variable il
existait avant le brexit donc quand on
prend toutes les difficultés une par une
en plus elles n'ont rien à voir avec le
brexit donc on voit le problème et
d'ailleurs ça montre bien en fait la
mauvaise foi sur le le Royaume-Uni vous
avez une sorte de cabale en fait anti
brexit ces derniers jours qui est basé
quand même sur sondage et le sondage
accrochez-vous bien il dit quoi il
demande au britanniqu par rapport à y a
3 ans est-ce que vous pensez que la
situation s'est amélioré ou empiré bah
on est en situation de crise donc
forcément il y a beaucoup de
Britanniques qui disent au niveau du
système de santé au niveau de l'économie
c'est plus difficile et donc ils ont
conclu que ils regrettent le brexit
faites le même sondage en France en
Allemagne si par rapport il a 3 ans ils
pensent que la situation a empiré je
pense qu'on va rigoler sur les résultats
et ça veut dire quoi ça veut donc dire
qu'en fait ils veul veul sortir de de
l'UE veul sortir de l'euro en fait c'est
une mauvaise foi intellectuelle
complètement dingue et malheureusement
on en est là-dedans en fait on cherche à
tout mettre sur le dos du brexit alors
comme je dis le Royaume-Uni a des
difficultés mais si c'est la catastrophe
au Royaume-Uni c'est l'apocalypse en
zone euro après il y a il y a quelque
chose sur lequel il faut aussi être être
objectif si si on sortait si on sortait
de Union européenne mais qu'on sortait
avec les clampins qu'on a à la gestion
oui ça serait
catastrophique si tu sors si tu fais un
frxit avec un Bruno Le Maire ministre de
l'Économie ça pas bien passer non plus
c'est juste l'enfer donc en fait selon
vous oui fa arrête avec les selon vous
oui selon moi enfin bruneo le maire n'a'
n'a pas quand même depuis le début qu'il
a pris le les reennes de l'économie en
France on peut pas dire qu'il est
objectivement brillé ici quand il dit
selon toi est-ce qu'il a BR pour créer
de la dette il est bien crard det oui
quand il dit qu'il a transformé
profondément l'économie française depuis
qu'il est au pouvoir B ça il l'a bien
transformé oui il il l'a mis il l'a mis
par terre donc il l'a bien transformé en
fait il s trompé pour faire mettre
l'économie russe à genou en fait il
aurait fallu nommer Bruno LEM ministre
de ministre des finan en Russie problème
c'est qu'il est minist le problème il
est ministre des finances mais en France
donc on est en France en fait si tu
gardes les mêmes équipes si tu gardes
les mêmes modes de pensé sit tu et
cetera évidemment que ça va être une
catastrophe vous pensez pas que leur
marge de manœuvre elle est est aussi
épaisse qu'une feuille de papier à
cigarette et que ce soit eux ou d'autres
clampins ou d'autres partis politiques
ça ne changera rien ah mais ça changera
rien puisque a il y a pas de parti
politique aujourd'hui enfin dans les
quatre majeurs il y a pas de parti
politique qui qui euh veuillent sortir
de de de de ce piège européen
aujourd'hui le RN veut pas sortir le LR
veut pas sortir les les le LFI veut pas
sortir et Macron veut pas sortir
donc personne aujourd'hui à part des des
des des des patriotes comme comme
charleshenri mais sinon le reste il a
toujours pas compris que le l'Europe
était était le piège qui nous envoyait
dans le fond enfin donc euh en fait ça
change tout parce que si vous reprenez
reprendre le contrôle c'est quoi fait
c'est une condition qui est nécessaire
mais comme l'a dit Olivier qui n'est pas
suffisante c'estàd que derrière vous
reprenez les manettes vous pouvez très
bien faire n'importe quoi reprenant les
manettes la seule différence c'est que
comme vous êtes à nouveau souverin
indépendant c'est que le guignol que
vous avez aux manettes vous pouvez le
virer à la prochaine élection et lui il
pourra faire une autre politique alors
dans le cadre de l'EU dans le cadre des
traités même si vous virireer le guignol
qui a l'URE actuelle B en fait la
personne qui va arriver dans le cadre là
elle va devoir mener la même politique
quand si on comend ce que j'explique
dans mon livre la partie énergie
immigration je veux dire sur l'énergie
la France aurait besoin de relancer le
4e génération aurait besoin de
reconstruire des réacteurs mais pas pas
h HE si on veut décarboner l'économie il
en faudrait il en faudrait beaucoup plus
ben elle pourra le faire en fait hors du
cadre de l' parce que vous n'aurez plus
la règle de la directive des 42,5 %
parce que EDF ne sera plus saccagé comme
c'est le cas l'heure actuel parce que
vous sortez complètement des règles du
marché l'électricité de l'Union
européenne vous remettez un monopole
public de de parce qu'en fait ça sert à
rien que EDF soit 100 % public super
vous épongez les pertes mais sauf qu'il
y a toujours la mise en concurrence il
va continuer à perdre de l'argent donc
ça sert strictement à rien et sur la
question de l'immigration vous pouvez là
aussi encore une fois bah vous
rétablissez des frontières nationales ça
va pas être la même au niveau de
l'immigration illégal et vous reprenez
aussi les manettes pour réduire
drastiquement l'immigration légale et
encore une fois moi je pense compte tenu
du stock qui est en France comp tenu des
problématiques qu'on connaît déjà il
faudrait effectivement passer
l'immigration zéro et complè illusoire
et c'est même inhumain pour certains
regroupement familial qui justifi et
autres mais on pourrait très bien passer
à quelques dizaines de milliers de
personnes par an question internet
attention il y a quand même enfin il
faut faut dire à propos de l'énergie
parce que à propos de l'immigration tu
peux voter des lois tu peux et et tu
peux je dirais donner un coup d'arrêt
assez rapidement mais l'énergie
construire une centrale ça se fait pas
en 6 mois donc de toute façon le
problème c'est que là on a aucune
volonté politique pour réellement
avancer c'est pas vrai non on a aucune
volonté politique mais mais mais non tu
peux pas tu peux pas sur ce sur ce genre
de chose tu ne peux pas sur ce genre de
chose changer d'avis comme de chemise si
tu veux si tu dis je ferme la veille et
que le lendemain tu dis je vais ouvrir
10 central ça ne se passe pas comme
ça concrètement là il y en a une qui a
démarré il y en a une qui a enfin dont
on a démarré
chaner un chanti on n fait un chantier
donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'
on Nura pas en fait de centrale
nucléaire avant 10 15 ans alors donc
pendant 15 ans va falloir ramer alors je
vais quand même ajouter une note
positive là-dessus parce que le cas qui
est à 7500 points c'est ça non non c'est
pas ça la not
mais c'est pas ça c'est que 10 15 ans
c'est l'équivalent en fait ce qui est
pour flamandville mais en fait si vous
en faites en masse exactement comme ce
qui été le cas lors du plan Mesmer ou
comme ce que font les Chinois vous
pouvez réduire ça à 6 7 ans pour des
grosses centrales même si c'est
compliqué et vous vous avez et vous avez
vous avez une autres pistes notamment
pour des sites industriels la la piste
des petits réacteurs modulaires où là
vous pouvez alors c'est de moindre
prisance mais vous pouvez alimenter des
sites industriels il y a une start-up
française là-dedans euh qui s'appelle
Nara qui est en plus sur la 4e
génération où il y a des pistes qui sont
intéressantes qui peut être développé et
ça ça se construit en beaucoup moins de
temps il y a des petits réacteurs
modulaires d'ailleurs sur des sur des
sous-marins nucléairirees russes donc il
y a il y a une piste là-dessus pour
aller sur des projets intermédiaires
mais pour ce qui est des grosses
centrales c'est certain ça se fait pas
du jour au lendemain même en y allant
plein pot avec plein de projets c'est
minimum 6 7 ans et de manière plus
réaliste on est plutôt sur du 10 ans
ouis il y avait agè panier du rché qui
nous avait exp runaché runaché
pardon qui nous avait expliqué que on
pouvait réinverser les choses avec sa
voiture en fait c'est sa voiture qui
pouvait être la centrale pour pour c'est
smart grid c'est plus compliqué ça ou
bah oui alors question internet qui qui
est d'ailleurs très juste que faiton du
milliard d'êtres humains qui vont devoir
quitter leur lieu de vie dans les
prochaines décennies surtout sachant que
nous en sommes les principaux
responsables c'estàdire les les sociétés
thermoindustrielles ont
gazé de CO2 notre atmosphère pendant
décennies ça dérègle le climat à l'heure
actuelle
on est quand même un peu responsable on
peut pas le dire on peut pas leur dire
vous gardez vos ressources fossiles dans
votre sol vous renoncez à votre
croissance à votre
industrialisation et vous n'estes pas
chez nous la France est plutôt bon élève
donc si on veut faire au principe de
responsabilité envoyez-les en Chine
envoyz aux États-Unis envoyez en
Allemagne envoyez les pas en France la
Chine produit nos
trucs pour nous on aocalis
aussi c'est un gros problème là vous
soulvez un vrai problème c'est que la
moitié de l'emprinte carbone de la
France c'est des importations et
effectivement pour baisser l'empreinte
de carbone et pas seulement les
émissions qu'on fait nous-mêmes il
faudrait c'est un argument souverainiste
s'il en est il faudrait relocaliser la
production parce que la production
française est infiniment plus basse au
niveau carbone que celle de Chine où il
y a encore énormément de charbon même
sil travaille sur des des centrales
nucléaires et autres donc une des clés
pour baisser l'empreinte carbone de la
France ça passe par la relocalisation
mais vous n'aurez pas de relocalisation
avec un coût de l'énergie qui est trop
cher donc on en revient exactement sur
ce qu'on disait parce que pour faire un
projet industriel dans un pays en gros
vous avez trois facteurs le capital
financier à combien vous allez lever
l'argent le capital humain c'est-à-dire
le le coût du du travail et vous avez la
question de l'énergie sauf que le
problème c'est si vous prenez le le gaz
depuis l'affaire russe le coût du gaz il
est à peu près 6 fois plus élevé en
Europe qu'aux États-Unis et 12 FO plus
élevé qu'en Chine parce qu'il y a un
contrat un méga contrat à terme entre la
Chine et la Russie vous avez en
parallèle un coup du travail qui est
bien plus faible en Chine et vous avez
le programme ira de subvention aux
États-Unis pour près de 300 milliards
bah si vous êtes un entrepreneur
industriel faut pas être un
devin pour deviner que les types ils
vont plutôt aller en Chine et aux
États-Unis qu'en Europe et donc la
question que fait-on du milliard d'êtres
humains qui vont devoir quitter leur
lieu de vie dans les prochaines
décennies
ben je crois que j'ai répondu si on
prend le principe de responsabilité
c'est la France n'a pas accueillir sa
part elle en a déjà assez
prise mais que
fait-on qu'est-ce que tu veux qu'on
réponde à ça on prend les 1 milliards
sur le sur les le le sur la
France ENF c'est débile comme remarque
non je pose des questions voilà bah je
réponds le jour où tu vas voouir faire
des remarques tu vas voir ça va piquer
non mais enfin excuse-moi mais c'est ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que fait-on
ben on les prend on les prend en France
un milliard c'est ridicule avez-vous
demandé au patronat français quelle
migration les
intéresse eux actuellement pour
développer ou carrément faire naître des
industries en
France mais on t'a expliqué que tu
pouvais pas faire naître d'industrie en
France si tu si tu tu avais ces couts de
l'énergie et question de Affre Jojo mais
oui mais tu tu ne peux pas tu peux pas
réindustrialiser un pays alors que les
les conditions dans
lesquels qui ont été mis en place et qui
ont fait partir les
gens n'ont pas
changé pourquoi veux-tu que les gens
reviennent pourquoi veux-tu que les gens
se réinstallent en France alors qu'ils
savent très bien qu'il vont se choper
des charges comme ils en ont pas dans
d'autres pays qui vont se
choper des charges d'accord dans le
charge produit charge donc qui vont se
choper des charges beaucoup plus
importantes que dans d'autres pays qui
vont se choper un état qui va leur
piquer 60 % de ce que de ce que de ce
qui gagne qu'ils vont se choper aussi
des prix qui sont beaucoup plus élevés
de l'énergie euh pour euh pour
travailler n'importe quel entrepreneur
se barre tu as vu dernièrement c'est
sorti hier ou avant-hier le sondage sur
le sur le le fait que les les les jeunes
diplômés euh
euh vont travailler à l'étranger 60 %
des jeunes alors c'est c'est pas qui
vont travailler c'est qui envisagent de
travailler à l'étrangervisag de
travailler à l'étranger bon ben voilà
on est on est dans un dans un système où
alors c'était mais c'est le même c'est
un grand problème que tu soulèves parce
que je le dis aussi dans mon livre
c'estàd qu'il y en a qui veulent nous
faire s'appelle comment le livre déjà il
s'appelle nos grand défis du 21e siècle
énergie im migration reprenons le
contrôle il est gratuit il est pas
gratuit vous pouvez l'acheter sur la la
boutique génér exit il est sur sur aussi
sur Amazon et on cherche à à développer
la la distribution mais ce que dit
Olivier c'est très V parce que certains
nous disent c'est n'importe quoi vaut
500000 faut prendre le sol de net sauf
que c'est pas les mêmes en fait qui
partent et c'est pas les mêmes qui
rentrent et quand pour répondre à la
question en fait l'immigration en France
elle est pasant industrielle d'ailleurs
l'industrie c'est des métiers qui sont
relativement bien payés et donc c'est
c'est il y a il y a tout un tas de de
Français qui vont faire le travail
l'immigration qu'on a c'est plus sur des
métiers de de service on va avoir ça
pour des cuisiniers pour des serveurs on
va avoir ça pour des services à la
personne on va en avoir aussi pour ce
que je parlais les livreurs uberits et
autres avec une voocation de pression à
la baisse sur les salaires et et ce truc
de métier enenstion et même qui qui est
une vision qui est quasiment raciste
pour moi de dire bah regarder sur ce
type de métier en fait c'est pas les
Français qui vont faire ça il faut aller
chercher justement de l'immigration vous
rendez compte s'il y a pas l'immigration
qui va le faire pour vous ça ça veut
dire en gros il y a que eux qui peuvent
faire ça mais sauf que c'est une vision
qui est complètement fausse en fait les
métiers d' ention c'est avant tout des
métiers difficile et qui sont mal payés
et comme par hasard quand vous augmentez
les salaires vous trouvez tout un tas de
petits français pour le faire un exemple
au Royaume-Uni le brexit chauffeur
routier qui est pas un métier facile bah
avant ils avaient que des Polonais qui
venaient faire le boulot effectivement
il les payit pas cher depuis le brexit
le il y a eu une pénurie parce que ils
sont repartis les Polonais le salaire
des chauffeurs routiers au Royaume-Uni a
augmenté de 40 % il est passé à 66000
pandes par an bizarrement vous trouviez
tout un tas de petits Anglais qui
étaient prêt à faire le job les métiers
en tension c'est des métiers qui sont
mal payés donc forme plutôt les million
de chôur Français augmenter les salaires
et bizarrement ces métiers soitdisant
qui seraient réservés avec une vision
encore une fois raciste qui serait
réservé quex immigrés vous allez trouver
tout un tas de français pour le faire et
d'ailleurs moi qui viens de la campagne
dans la campagne ces métiers là ils sont
bien souvent fait par les Français je
viens de la
nièvreère est-ce que vous souhaitez
aborder jur savoir quelle campagne je v
j j c'est pas une campagne ah
ouais est-ce que est que vous avez un
sujet que vous souhaitez aborder avec
nous
l'agriculture la transition écologique
la transition
énergétique des sujets comme ça tu veux
qu'on parle de moi j'aimerais bien
parler du à l'Europe des des Bours aussi
de de gestion quand on est sur les trucs
UBS pour moi il y en a deux qui m'ont
marqué en plus que j'ai pour le coup
révélé c'est les emprints d'excès sur
l'inflation et c'est le la gestion du
plan de relance de l'Union européenne
alors pour
pour soutenir leses c'est pour faire
honorable c'est un plan de relance des
banques c'est parce que c'était
intéressant pour nous c'est parce qu'on
anticipé une inflation basse c'est
pourquoi alors en fait je me fait un peu
candide oui c'est très bien c'est ce
qu'il faut il faut faut expliquer d'où
ça part en fait à la base les emprunts
question l'inflation c'est pas né sous
Macron c'est né sous DSK en
98 domos notre ami du
sopitel ami du du FMI oui aussii
effectivement mais je crois qu'il est
resté dans l'histoire plus pour le le
sopitel euh Dominic strosan qu'est-ce
qu'il a fait il s'est dit bah c'est
génial c'est la modernité on va faire
des empreinttes d'excès sur
l'inflation alors à l'époque c'était un
peu différent parce qu'on avait des Toau
fix cétait un peu plus élevé
effectivement les les perspectives
d'inflation n'étaient pas forcément
haussière donc il pouvait se dire
pourquoi pas mais ça reste en fait un
Paris contre les marchés donc c'est très
hasardeux alors que normalement le rôle
du Trésor et c'est inscrit dans ces
statut vous pouvez Mme le retrouver sur
leur site c'est de d'assurer la
protection du contribuable donc là on
n'est pas vraiment là-dedans le problème
étant que après les conditions
économiques ne sont plus les mêmes et je
reviens en fait à la la période de
création monétaire de la de la BCE la
création monétaire de la BCE a fait que
vous aviez des taux d'intérêt fixe qui
étaient extrêmement bas de telle sorte
que et d'ailleurs c'était pour vous avez
un communiqué de de la de la BCE qui
explique que justement le but
de ça c'est de faire baisser les taux et
de relancer l'inflationon avait une
inflation qui était très basse là il
nous fut un choc volkerur voilà là ils
font l'inverse mais mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que c'est dire que en 2009
2019 et 2020 vous empruntiez à des taux
fixe qui était négatif ou
nul il faut être un prix Nobel pour se
dire bah dans cette période là alors je
peux emprunter à taux nul ou à taux
négatif je vais continuer à émettre des
empruns indexés sur l'inflation et ben
manque de PO c'est ce qu'ils ont fait
alors que le la BCE voulait relancer
l'inflation donc c'estàd que c'était
perdant à tous les coups et quand vous
regardez ce qu'on appelle le le point
mort d'inflation en 2019 et 2020 il
était sûr que desmettes ça allait être
perdant c'est qu volume ça 2019 et 2020
bon ça doit être à peu près 30 milliards
parce qu'ils émettent à peu près 15
milliards 15 milliards par an de deati
oatiu alors il il y a ceux qui sont
indexé sur l'inflation en France ce soit
indexé sur l'inflation en zone euro et
ce coût là il est quand même absolument
important parce que l'inflation
évidemment est revenu comme par hasard
mais on le savait 2022 je vois je vois
Olivier rigoler mais oui 2022 le coût 16
milliards d'euros 2023 14 milliards
d'euros c'est soi-disant l'économie
qu'on allait faire avec la réforme des
retraites enfin c'est même plus c'est ce
coup là sauf qu'il y a encore 54
milliards de cou l'attend quand tout va
être débouclé c'est quand même pareil un
54 milliards c'est la même chose que
pour le bouclier tarifire c'est le le
budget de la défense et au lieu de 446
hôpitaux ça peut-être 450
hôpitaux ça on peut remercier notre
génie Bruno Le Maire là-dessus parce que
il y a des pays l'Allemagne a décidé
d'arrêter les empreintes
questioninflation le Royaume-Uni avait
vu le truc venir ils avaient réduit
aussi la voileure des émissions il y en
av qu'on avait émis peu et cetera Bruno
le mer lui il continue et moi j'is fait
une alerte auprès de la Cour des comptes
là-dessus la Cour des comptes
d'ailleurs a dit dans son langage fait
une alerte à quel titre privé on peut
faire un signalement auprès de la Cour
des comptes j'ai fait un signalement
auprès de la Cour des comptes que ça me
paraissait délirant à la fois de
continuer à le faire parce que ça
présentait des risques financiers que
c'était criminel de l'avoir fait entre
2019 et 2020 vous avez une réponse ils
ont pas fait de réponse parce qu'après
il le gardent mais il a un rapport en en
mai 2022 où ils disent qu'il faudrait
peut-être revoir la voilure là-dessus
sauf que vous regardez au niveau des
émissions ça continue quoi qu'il arrive
ils émettent entre 10 et 12 % de la
dette chaque année ça continue cette
année tous les mois tous les mois ils
émettent des emprunts d'excession
surinflation donc ils ont parTenu la
leçon là où d'autres pays l'ont fait et
l'autre point c'est le plan de relance
de l'Union européenne là aussi on est
sur d'autres types de génie c'est-à-dire
que rappelez-vous il y a l'accord en
2020 où ils se disent on va faire un
grand emprunt de l'Union européenne pour
relancer et moi je me disais en tant que
B gestionnaire normalement bah 2020-
2021 les taux sont très bas les 800
milliards ils vont tout emprunter
directement et puis par curiosité je
suis allé voir ces empruntsunion
européenne parce que je me doutais que
c'était en plus à des taux qui étaient
supérieurs à ce que pouvait obtenir la
France ce qui est le cas mais en fait
quand j'ai regardé dans le détail je me
suis rendu compte que à fin 2022 ils
avaient pas tout emprunté il leur
restait 636 milliards d'euros à
emprunter sauf que les taux ils étaient
plus de zéro maintenant ils empruntent
entre 3 et 3 et demi en taux j'ai
calculé ce que ça représentait en
intérêt c'estàd qu'en seul intérêt
au niveau de l'Union européenne ça va
coûter 211 milliards d'intérêts
là-dessus comme pour toute dépense de
l'Union européenne la France paye 17,4 %
ça veut dire qu'on va payer 37 milliards
d'euros d'intérêts combien la France
reçoit du plan de relance de l'Union
européenne 37 milliards sauf qu'on va
rembourser le capital 73 milliards
c'est-à-dire que ce plan de relance de
l'Union européenne infin à cause de
l'erreur de gestion à la base ça devait
coûter 40 milliards en net à cause de
l'erreur de gestion de pas avoir tout
emprunté dès le début ça va coûter 73
milliards d'euros en net à la France
déjà à la base fallait être un génie
pour signer ce plan de relance que je
rappelle que c'est un truc où vous
deviez payer 80 milliards pour recevoir
40 vous n'avez pas la libtilisation des
40 et en plus derrière on vous dit vous
devez faire la réforme des retraites
vous devez faire la réforme de
l'assurance chômage mais du fait de
cette gestion on va pas payer 40 on va
payer 73 milliards d'euros donc bravo à
Emmanuel Macron qui ce plan de relance
et bravo aux grands gestionnaires au
niveau de l'Union européenne qui savent
emprunter et qui qui savent sentir que
quand il y a de l'inflation il y aura
jamais de remonter des taux et donc
c'est quandme m dommage de ne pas avoir
emprunté Olivier un sujet que que tu
veux tu voulais aborder ou là aussi j'ai
fait un signalement d'ailleurs à la cour
des compte sur l'affaire du plan de
relance de lieu là pour le moment ils
ont pas ils ont pas
bougé alors le vin jaune comment il est
cette année le vin jaune va être bien
cette année un sujet sérieux euh mais ça
c'est sérieux
euh les agriculteurs non ce qui ce qui
est intéressant c'est bah justement les
agriculteurs si tu veux je trouve qu'on
ne on n fait pas des tonnes on en fait
plus des tonnes sur euh sur les les
dérapage de de de de pardieu que sur euh
la centaine de milliers de de tracteurs
qui ont bloqué tout à Berlin et sachant
que sachant que le le le rail allemand a
l'air de s'y MRE et et d'autres donc et
les camionneurs
donc peut-être que euh les gens vont se
réveiller euh réellement en Allemagne
euh parce que nous on a Bruno mais eux
ils ont Olaf hein c'est pas mieux euh
Bruno et Olaf sont sur un bateau oui eu
et j'ai vu que Olaf d'ailleurs félicit
chaleureusement Gabriel pour son
accession euh comme premier ministre
euh c'est normal oui c'est ou oui oui
c'est c'est plutôt normal mais enfin de
toute façon chose que Gabriel Attal soit
nommé au Premier ministre ben je pense
que c'est le c'est je dirais c'est un
c'est un non événement parce que de
toute façon ça se déroule et ça ça va
continuer à se dérouler je pense que
c'est le signe
de que que
Manuel Macron n'emmerde pas que les non
vaccinés c'est-à-dire qu'en gros il dit
je fais ce que je veux je nomme qui je
veux et j'emmerre tout le monde en fait
c'est ça le signal alors que ça je pense
que alors j'en discutais avec quelqu'un
à midi qui m'a qui m'a donné une bonne
idée pour mes mes scénarios de de
janvier parce qu'il me disait il me
disait en fait lui pense c'est pas c'est
pas mal comme comme
scénario il dit nomme Gabriel Atal parce
que ça va être le le gentil la gentille
majorette qui va continuer à dérouler le
programme mais là où ça risque de
coincer c'est les européennes parce que
les
européennes
avec avec ce qui se se passe depuis un
bon moment je pense qu'il y a quand même
pas mal de gens qui sont un peu énervés
et qui vont
voter probablement pour le RN aux
européennes d'accord et si on se
retrouve avec
avec l'assemblée européenne avec je sais
pas dans les différents pays 30 ou 40 %
pour le RN ça changera pas grand-chose
au niveau européen puisque ça va
continuer à dérouler sur sur l'Europe
mais en revanche ça risque d'être un
petit peu compliqué en France et euh et
on se disait dans ce
cas-là pourquoi pas une dissolution de
l'Assemblée anticipée par par
Macron pour en fait mettre le RN dans la
merde pour 2027 pourquoi bah parce que
on va se retrouver avec un Bardella en
premier ministre Bardella en premier
ministre qui évidemment ne fera rien
et
continuera dans la même dans la même
optique le Premier ministre n'a pas le
pouvoir du référendum qui peut être le
moyen de débloquer effectivement voilà
et donc qu'est-ce qui va se passer bah
il va se passer que le RN va couler et
va va démontrer en étant aux affaires
qu'il est aussi nul que que le le
restant et et à ce moment-là euh et à ce
moment-là Macron reprend la main pour
2027tel en chef d'orchestre déroulant
une
partition non en en en dans la la suite
si tu veux il va il va nous gratifier de
quelques 493 pour faire passer les
conneries qu'ils ont à faire passer donc
as usual quoi tu vois on va on va
continuer à dérouler ce qui ce que
Macron veut dérouler sur les 6 mois qui
vont courir jusqu'aux élections
européenes zé le compteur de 493 en un
nouveau pr ça va ça va se faire
gentiment de toute façon il est aux
ordres qu'est-ce que tu qu'
disent il va dire oui monsieur tout de
suite monsieur et
donc qui vous dit qu'il va faire ça he
et puis et puis
un il le détruit au
passage d'accord parce que tu as jamais
vu un il Luse il a pris beaucoup de
cheveux blancs depuis qu'il est au
gouvernement oui oui oui oui oui je mis
oui enfin bon allez euh je m'étendrai
pas là-dessus mais c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas le sujet
le sujet c'est que c'est
que en fait tu as tu as une continuité
des choses ça ne changera strictement
rien ni à la politique ni à quoi que ce
soit d'ailleurs tu vois que les pois
lourd poids lourd très très lourd en ce
qui concerne Bruno Le Maire euh je sais
pas il a été nommé à quelque chose
françois b commissaire au Plan on sait
pas ce qu'il fait mais il planifie euh
et tu as duupont Moretti qui est resté
en place tu as Darmanin qui est resté en
place qui a refusé la défense c'est ça
qui ça isabeth born qui aurait refusé la
défense mais en fait ce remaniement faut
dire les choses les Français en fait
s'en fichent complètement j' c'est un
truc qui n'intéresse que les
journalistes et les Français se font peu
d'illusion sur ce que ça va changer
Gabriel Atal en lui-même c'est quoi vos
sources bah je parle avec les gens dans
la rue et demander aux gens ça les
intéresse le remanement je pense que à
part sur bfmt TV sur les médias où ils
sont tous à fond làdessus le français
moyen se f que tu penses que la
politique va changer non la politique va
pas
changer moi je connais personne qui m'a
dit attention j'attends depuis des jours
là j'en peux plus savoir qui va être
ministre de la Défense pour Emmanuel
Macron j'ai personne qui m'a dit
ça ça va rien changer ce qui est
intéressant c'est la suite la suite
peut-être alors peut-être que ça se
passera pas comme ça mais ça pourrait
être intéressant ça pourrait être
intéressant c'est
ça serait probablement catastrophique
pour le pays parce que on se
retrouverait encore une fois avec un
Macron bis en 2027 et ils auraient le
temps de de mettre complètement à plat
la France mais c'est leur but hein donc
pourquoi vous dites c'est leur but mais
parce que c'est il y a un moment en
effet tu vois où je je disais
systématiquement ils sont incompétents
et puis finalement je me dis euh d'abord
ça dépasserait l'entendement qui soit
aussi incompétent que ça et second do il
y a quand même des choses où tu te dis
il y a pas que de l'incompétence il y a
aussi très probablement une énorme
corruption voilà et parce qu'il y a des
choix qui sont faits où tu te dis c'est
pas possible
que ce ne soit que de
l'incompéten parce que il y a tellement
de
d'enjeux de pognon
que tu te dis forcément ça revient d'une
manière ou d'une autre et ça
revient pas
que dans des pays d'Afrique ou
autres vous avez des preuves non j'ai
évidemment que tu peux pas en avoir de
preuve tu ne peux pas en avoir ceci dit
il y a quand même beaucoup de
politiques qui curieusement en ayant
jamais rien foutu de leur vie sauf de la
politique se retrouve avec des
patrimoines assez extraordinaires que
quelqu'un qui euh gagne enfin ou en tout
cas est censé gagner
euh de 3 qu C fois plus
que serait bien incapable d'acheter
voilà je dis juste ça alors la
corruption moi j'ai j'ai j'ai pas de
preuve mais il y a aussi n'empêche une
part d'idéologie parce que si vous avez
pas de preuve mais c'est pour ça moi je
je je dis rien mais quand quand il y a
aussi une part d'idéologie quand
quelqu'un avant même le le dérapage sur
le financement du plan de relance de
l'UE quand quelqu'un comme Emmanuel
Macron
signe un projet où le projet c'est de
dire je te prends 80 et je te rends 40
je aucun chef d'entreprise saint-desprit
qui signerait ça j'ai envie de dire même
un demeuré ne signerait pas ça mais
Emmanuel Macron il est pas demeuré s'il
le fait ça veut dire quoi quand il fait
ça ça veut dire que c'est quelqu'un qui
par idéologie mais on le voit sur tous
les sujets est prêt à sacrifier tous les
intérêts nationaux
au nom de l'Union européenne vous ne
connaissez pas les intérêts a une part
d'idéologie qui lu ont qui l'ont poussé
à
signerintérêt de la France pas le seul
intérêt c'est un inérêt de l'Union
européenne d'autres pays qui vont
recevoir de l'argent ou c'est de se dire
bah en faisant ça je verrouille encore
plus la France dans l'Union européenne
parce que je mets des engagements
financiers c'est c'est une façon de
c'est une sorte de mariage forcé en fait
vous forcez les gens par ses intérêts
financiers à se dire bah on doit rester
ensemble parce qu' a ses engagements
financiers donc je pense que c'est une
façon de verrouiller encore plus la
France dans l'Union européenne et il le
fait bien par idéologie c'est-à-dire
pour l'Union européenne je vais
sacrifier les intérêts de la France et
ça a été la même chose depuis 30 ans sur
la question de l'énergie et c'est
d'ailleurs la même chose sur tout un tas
de sujets à chaque fois en fait on est
prêt les dirigeants français sont prêts
à tous cider au nom de l'Union
européenne et même à trahir et à
sacrifier l'intérêt national Olivier tro
livres à conseill à la comm communauté
et un conseil pour les jeunes
générations et ensuite à Charles Henry
de répondre à cette question tris livres
le
sien le sien c'est interdit de faire ça
là he pour c'est interdit de faire ça
non mais je suis désolé c'est c'est un
des derniers que j'ai lu donc fallait
bien que je lise pour le pour faire la
PR intéressant c'est intéressant oui
c'est intéressant tu l'as préfacé c'est
ça bah en plus donc tu as des intérêts
dedans ou pas pas conf in non pas du
tout donc deux autres euh deux autres
écoute je suis en train de lire un un un
excellent euh euh Pol qui se passe en
Chine et qui euh mais je je incapable de
te te te donner ni l'auteur ni le ni le
titre euh qui fait partie d'une d'une
série et qui euhqu c'est à ta femme qui'
ouais mais qui m'en apprend qui m'en
apprend sur qui en apprend beaucoup sur
euh euh la la
révolution chinoise la révolution
culturelle et cetera et c'est assez
intéress sûr que tu as piqué ça à ta
femme ouis mais c'est assez intéressant
et un deè un trè par un trè un trè ben
un livre que je que je voulais lire mais
que je n'ai pas encore eu le temps de le
faire c'est le le dernier
bouquin
non non je'
non non non non non non donc le trè non
le 3è c'était c'est un c'est le livre de
le dernier livre de Charles Gave voilà
que je voulais lire mais que je n'ai pas
encore lu voilà ça vous intéresserait de
discuter avec des économistes qui n'ont
pas votre vision des choses et bien tu
sais j'ai fait ça pendant un bon moment
sur BFM et après sur RT France tu vois
donc ça m'est arrivé beaucoup alors il y
en a quelques-uns
euh où je me suis toujours demandé euh
ce qu'il
pouvait comment ils avaient pu se se
qualifier d'économiste parce que c'était
c'était juste pathétique euh mais après
euh oui c'est toujours intéressant
maintenant maintenant si tu veux le le
tu as tu as quand même beaucoup
d'économistes pour moi qui sont des
économistes universitaires et et pour
moi ça me pose un problème pourquoi bah
parce que si tu veux l'universitaire
c'est c'est je l'ai dit plusieurs fois
et peut-être même ici
mais tu peux lire tous les bouquins de
Sénat et de Prost si je te mets dans une
formule 1 tu vas te planter au premier
virage et ben c'est pour moi
l'universitaire c'est un peu ça alors
ils font des calculs ils font des trucs
sur le sur le papier qui marche
toujoursin sur le papier c'est c'est euh
euh tu sais la je crois que c'est une
phrase de déproche qui disait j'aimerais
vivre en Théorie parce que en Théorie
tout se passe bien et bien là c'est un
peu ça sauf que malheureusement
euh ça se passe mal quand tu arrives
dans la réalité et c'est pour ça que euh
je j'ai dit euh c'est c'est
Charles-Henri qui a dit ça au départ
j'ai j'ai préfacé son son bouquin parce
que euh il me semble être un économiste
de terrain comme moi je suis un
économiste de terrain pourquoi bah parce
que j'ai monté mon entreprise je suis
chef d'entreprise et l'économie c'est
mon métier
donc et ça je pense que nous on sait
conduire la Formule 1
voilà trois livres charleshenri et le
conseil pour les jeunes générations non
ça t'intéresse pas benah le conseil pour
les jeunes génération je leur dirais de
de de réfléchir à deux fois la prochaine
fois qu'il mettent un bulletin de vote
dans le dans dans le lon parce que la
deuxième fois l'élection de Macron ça
m'a ça m'a j'ai ça m'a un peu dérangé
avant de de de redonner la parole
charleshenri faisons une expérience de
penser si je vous écoute tout est
noir la France dans 3 ans elle sera
où on je sais pas si c'est dans 3 ans
mais mais je pense que si on continue
comme ça dans dans dans 10 15 ans la la
France c'est un épat géant voilà en
faillite ah bah on est déjà en faillite
donc oui on sera là pour le coup c'estce
que c'est un NP pas dans fite c'est
Soleil Vert ben ça sera un peu ça ça ça
je pense queon sera plus dans une
démocratie ça c'est c'est c'est déjà le
cas donc on n'est plus dans une
démocratie parce que bah oui parce que
si si tu veux penser qu'on est en
démocratie parce que tous les 5 ans on
va mettre mettre un petit bulletin c'est
une fausse idée on voit que la
démocratie elle est bouffée tous les
jours on voit que en fait il y a plus de
contrepouvoir il y a plus de il y a plus
de réel journalistes il y a plus de donc
il y a plus de démocratie aujourd'hui en
en en en France et puis pour avoir une
démocratie il faudrait qu'on récupère
notre souveraineté et on l'a pas donc on
n plus dans une démocratie ça depuis
assez longtemps mais là je pense que ça
va être de pire en pire
ous plus en plus de de de contrôle de tu
tu tu entends parler beaucoup
d'euronumérique c'est pour contrôler on
tu
entendsas une espèce de politique de
peur en permanence qui font que on va te
retirer tes libertés les unes après les
autres les ETF
Bitcoin je m'en fous voilà TR livres
charleshenri on va
prendre roman pour moi qui est le plus
beau roman sans doute le les Frères
Karamazov de dostyevski et après sur des
livres plus politique j'aurais
dit David Kandet le secret de l'Occident
qui qui décrit un petit peu ce que je
disais tout à l'heure c'est ce qui a
fait la richesse de de l'Occident c'est
tout l'inverse du modèle de l'Union
européenne c'estàd c'est parce qu'il y
avait une diversité parce qu'il y avait
des modèles différents et on avait
tendance à imiter bizarrement celui qui
marchait à prendre des des parties et
avoir tout un tas de modèles pas tous
les deux dans le même panier c'est ce
qu'a fait la la richesse de l'odent
c'est très intéressant à lire à comparer
avec le système de l'Union européenne et
aussi politique Douglas Meray lestran
suicide de l'Europe sur la question
migratoire qui a été le livre le plus
vendu au Royaume-Uni qui est aussi assez
assez excellent avant le conseil pour
les jeunes générations un commentaire de
Raphaël te marre pas parce que tu vas
prendre dans les dents je m'en fous
complètement tu sais alors Rapha il me
semble que les économistes universitaire
travaille sur des données statistiques
que vous avez mentionné dans vos propos
de fait les économistes universitaires
sont donc mauvais car ils utilisent les
données de l'INC de l'OCDE de l'ONU et
cetera les sans esprit critique les
mêmes données que vous CIT c'est-à-dire
qu'il communique il n'analysese pas
voilà et ça c'est ça j'en ai vu un
certain nom passer avec moi sur sur sur
les les médias où ces gens-là prennent
des chiffres sans souvent savoir même
comment ils sont calculés c'est ça qui
est qui est assez passionnant moi j'en
ai eu quelques-uns qui devant moi
étaient incapable de me dire comment on
calculer les chiffres du chômage par
exemple aux États-Unis ce qui est en
plus assez assez amusant parce que là
pour le coup tout est publique et ça
s'appelle ça
s'appelle s'appelle là où tu vas
chercher tes chiffres aux États-Unis
c'est vachement bien ça s'appelle ah ben
c'est le c'est le le le Bureau flabor of
statistic BLS bon le BLS tu as tout
dedans et c'est et c'est assez
intéressant c'est assez intéressant
parce que la plupart des économistes qui
ne qui vont te commenter pendant des
heures des chiffres
américains sont incapables de te dire
comment ils sont calculés et c'est ça
qui devient très intéressant c'est que
justement les chiffres américains sont
complètement bidonnés sur le sur le
chômage américain pourquoi parce que
rigan avait fait installer un algorithme
en prenant en
compte le les supposées créations
d'entrepris c'est quoi ta source ma
source c'est c'est la recherche voilà
c'est c'est ce que Raphaël visiblement
fait pas euh ça c'est gratuit oui mais
je m'en fous c'est la c'est la c'est
c'est la recherche rigan c'est c'est
amusant comme histoire je vais lui
raconter comme ça ça lui apprendra
quelque chose euh r rigan en 82 83
euh dit
euh en fait au BLS et Raphaël profiton
remets une question pendant qu'il parle
vas-y il faut il faut il faut trouver
quelque chose parce que euh ça ne me
rend pas justice euh ces chiffres de
l'emploi américain et le BLS fait une
petite formule de calcul en euh prenant
une moyenne d'entreprise créées aux
États-Unis et en disant bah voilà ces
entreprises qui sont créées elles
engagent en moyenne de trois personnes
et donc
euh on va corriger les données qu'on a
de ces de ce de cet algorithme qui va
nous fournir des gens qui sont supposés
être
engagés truc de fou parce que ça ne
correspond à rien alors que il y a un
truc qui serait très facile c'est
demander à l'IRS américain puisque le le
l'impôt est prélevé à la source donc ils
savent eux ils ont les chiffres exacts
de l'emploi aux États-Unis mais on leur
demande pas eux on fait des sondages
d'une part des sondages et ensuite on
corrige ses sondages avec ce cette
méthode de calcul qu'est-ce que ça a
donné parce que c'est ça qui est
intéressant en
où crise économique on peut penser qu'il
y a eu plus
de chute d'entreprise que de création
d'entreprise en N d'accord et bien ce
petit ce petit calcul rajoute
840000 créations d'emplois sur l'année
c'est pas rien 840000 d'accord et
figurez-vous que en
2009 ce petit calcul a créé exnilo
970000 emplois voilà
alors tu veux quand j'ai en face de moi
un économiste qui me commente les
chiffres de l'emploi américain en me
disant oh il y en a 15000 de moins que
prévu mais qui ne sait pas comment il ce
ce chiffre est calculé ça m'embête un
peu voilà Raphaël n'a pas mis d'autres
questions euh question une autre
question que j'attrape au vol avant le
dernier le conseil pour les jeunes
générations étant donné que Monsieur de
la marche vit en Suisse peut-il nous
expliquer comment le pays s'en sort
aussi bien avec environ 25 % d'étrangers
et une croissance migratoire en hausse
constante alors euh je rappelle que la
Suisse n'a pas le droit du sol donc pour
avoir la nationalité suisse il faut que
tu y travailles tu y résides pendant 10
ans d'accord
et et au bout de 10 ans on te fait
passer un
examen pour savoir si tu t'es bien il y
a une enquête pour savoir si tu t'es
bien intégré justement si tu parles avec
des Suisses si tu et copain avec des
Suisses comment tu te comportes et
cetera et euh euh si tu dois parler une
des trois langues suisses donc
l'allemand l'italien ou le français euh
et et à la suite de cette de cette
enquête on peut te donner ou pas ta
nationalité suisse donc tu vois c'est
très différent parce que en fait les
gens qui sont en Suisse ils
veulent et les gens qui ont la
nationalité suisse ils veulent avoir la
nationalité Suisse ils veulent vivre en
Suisse aujourd'hui tu as des gens en
France
qui ne supportent pas la France ou en
tout cas beaucoup des côtés de la France
mais qui sont parce qu'ils sont nés là
ça c'est ta
perception non ils le disent eux-mêmes
il y en a
beaucoup il ils sont quand même sur le
sol français et ils sont quand ils ont
quand même la nationalité française
alors qu'on ne leur demande rien raphaë
dépêche-toi ouais non et surtout aussi
en Suisse au moindre écart c'estàdire
que l'expulsion des étrangers
délinquants en Suisse au moindre écart
ça dégage du territoire national c'est
pas vraiment le cas en
France al je vais essayer de parler
lentement pour c'est une démocratie la
Suisse aussi le le juste au passage il y
a des votations tout le temps voilà je
je vais parler doucement pour que
Raphaël puisse finir sa question qu'il
est en train d'écrire il a arrêté sa
question un conseil pour les jeunes
générations charleshenri
réfléchissez réfléchissez par vous-même
aimez la France parce que si vous aimez
pas votre pays il y a personne d'autre
qui va qui va l'aimer pour vous et et
surtout moi pourquoi je me suis engagé
en politique assez jeune j'avais
absolument aucun
intérêt à faire ça c'est que je me
disais que sachant l'état du pays
sachant ses problèmes je me voyais pas
en fait me me regarder dans une glace et
me dire tu n'as rien fait pour empêcher
ça et donc j'espère que si ma génération
vous avez quel âge j'ai 35 ans vous
gagnez combien ça vous regarde pas je
pose la question vous croyez en Dieu
vous avez un ami imaginaire non pas
vraiment ça va j'ai pas d'amis
imaginaire mais mais vous gagnez combien
je vais répéter ça me regardez pas non
je me disais en tout cas je suis pas
payé de la de la politique c'est pas
c'est pas mon métier et est-ce que je me
et je me je me disais voilà que si ma
génération n'arrive pas à reprendre le
contrôle j'espère en tout cas que les
les jeunes générations reprendront le le
flambeau comme disait le vous avez des
enfants pas encore non vous comptez en
faire ça on
verra donc je vous laisse terminer votre
phrase faisant 2,1 2,1 pour le le
renouvellement et et donc voilà que que
ces jeunes générations reprennent le le
flambeau si si nous on y arrive pas
parce que je pense que un pays qui a
2000 ans d'histoire comme comme la
France qui est une des plus belles
histoires du monde on n pas le droit de
de de l'abandonner et et j'espère en
tout cas j'espère que ça ser fa avec ma
génération mais si c'est pas le cas
j'espère que les jeunes générations qui
m'écoutent et qui nous écoutent ce soir
sauront reprendre le flambeau et sauront
réussir si nous
échouons messieurs
[Musique]
merci